le sujet central de notre émission de ce
soir est de ceux qui déchaîne les
passions
je veux parler de la cohabitation sur le
sol français de populations d'origines
différentes
n'ayant ni la même culture ni la même
religion ni les mêmes valeurs
notre avenir pourtant va dépendre de la
façon dont nous serons résoudre ce
problème séculaire mais qui se pose
aujourd'hui avec une ampleur toute
particulière
l'apparition du front national puis de
sos racisme a modifié les données de
notre débat politique et tous les
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
devront en tenir compte
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
invité ce soir monsieur harlem désir
président de sos racisme le plus grand
mouvement de jeunesse qui se soient
créés en france ils sont apparus en
france depuis la dernière guerre
harlem désir 27 ans licencié en histoire
et en philosophie
inconnu il y a trois ans il faut bien le
dire catholique de culture est français
depuis plusieurs siècles par sa mère
alsacienne et par son père martiniquais
avec vous monsieur désir nous allons
essayer de faire le bilan de votre
action depuis l'existence d'espèces
racisme vous n'avez pas enrayer la
progression du front national
est ce qu'au moins vous avez le
sentiment d'avoir réussi à faire reculer
le racisme dans ce pays
à quoi sert finalement votre mouvement
qui êtes vous vous même
où vous situez-vous que proposez vous
êtes vous comme le disent ses
détracteurs
une pure création des médias et du parti
socialiste
ou bien est-ce que vous représentez une
nouvelle façon comme le disent vos fans
une nouvelle façon de faire de la
politique
faut-il voir dans sos racisme l'un de
ces partis modulaire et intermittents
dont le sociologue americatho flers dit
qu'ils domineront la vie politique du
xxième siècle et qu'il n'est tron et
disparaîtront au gré des problèmes de
société on vous interroger sur toutes
ces questions et bien être tandem
habituel alain duhamel albert du roy
avec ce soir henri amouroux henri
amouroux du journal rhône alpes et du
figaro magazine qui va nous aider à
resituer les problèmes actuels
dans une perspective historique amoureux
est en effet l'auteur de nombreux livres
sur une époque où le racisme
représentait dans notre pays une réalité
autrement tragique
je veux parler de l'époque de
l'occupation allemande
alors avant de donner la parole à svp
pour vers le feu des questions et ajouts
en lui le sel nous allons regarder les
sujets donc que les français
souhaiteraient que vous abordiez ce soir
tels qu'ils ont été recensés grâce au
télé sondage de la sofres
alors en tête en tête des demandes les
relations entre les français les
immigrés cinquante deux pour cent des
personnes que nous avons interrogées
souhaitent que vous leur parlez des
relations entre français et immigrés
cela ne vous surprendra pas bien ensuite
votre attitude de la gare du front
national 41% la lutte contre le racisme
38% volaille trois sujets que les gens
souhaitent vouloir aborder ce soir et
tout de suite la première question avoue
jean-louis le sel harlem désir bonsoir
bonsoir question ici sur les idées que
vous défendez le racisme la réforme du
code de la nationalité
la délinquance des jeunes immigrés leur
possible intégration les propos
insultants que vous auriez tenus à
l'égard de fonctionnaires de police et
bien sûr le phénomène le pen mais la
plupart des interrogations des
téléspectateurs vous concerne
personnellement quel est votre
profession d'où proviennent vos
ressources et celle de sos racisme dans
quelle arme avez vous fait votre service
militaire et surtout celle ci que je
vous pose en premier
pourquoi vous appelez-vous harlem ce
n'est pas un prénom mais à écouter il se
trouve que si c'est mon prénom
il ya des gens qui visiblement ne
l'acceptent pas puisque j'ai lu dans
certains journaux j'ai entendu dire
qu'on voulait absolument d'appeler jean
philippe
je crois qu'il faut régler la question
une fois pour tout aussi jean philippe
alors jean philippe c'est mon deuxième
prénom il se trouve que comme tous les
français j'ai un premier prénom c'est le
seul d'ailleurs dont je n'ai jamais eu
usage
et puis j'ai un deuxième prénom alors
pour que la question soit réglée je
crois que le plus simple
comme j'avais quand même prévu qu'on ne
la poserai françois henri de virieu
c'est que vous regardiez vous même mes
papiers alors moi je vois ici non désir
prénom harlem il n'y a pas de virgules
jean-philippe yonne une esquisse
de trait d'union entre jean et philippe
voilà je pense que j'ai enfilé vérité
historique établi alors pourquoi harlem
quand même voilà pourquoi relève alors
d'abord pourquoi désir on pourrait se
demander parce que des gens ont dit
c'est un nom trop beau pour être vrai
nom martine hugot nouveau à la hâte un
non martiniquais alors vous savez aux
antilles c'était souvent les maîtres ou
les bonnes soeurs qui donnaient les noms
aux esclaves est bon nous on nous a
appelés désir ça me vient de mon père
qui est d'ailleurs avec nous ce soir
harlem c'est le prénom que mes parents
ont décidé de me donner en référence je
crois aux noirs américains qui sont donc
des noirs en exil d'une certaine façon
sont des esclaves qu'on a été prendre en
afrique mais maintenant qu'ils sont aux
etats-unis bien il faut qu'il se
construise une nouvelle identité et
harlem c'est le symbole de ces noirs qui
sont maintenant des noirs des états unis
d'amérique
et puis jean philippe c'est parce que
mon père s'appelle jean marie donc jean
et philippe parce que mon grand père
maternel du côté de ma mère c'était
alsacienne s'appelle philippe et donc ça
fait arlene comme premier prénom et
jean-philippe comme deuxième prénom
d'accord tout ça est très claire une
petite précision vous avez fait un
service militaire
oui alors sur mon service militaire donc
j'ai été appelé j'ai fait mes trois
jours j'ai été incorporé dans l'armée de
terre
j'ai été ensuite réformé pour raison
médicale mais je suis toujours
réservistes vous avez en bonne santé
pourquoi je suis en bonne santé vous
savez les militaires ont leurs raisons
que la société civile ignore bien alors
alain duhamel pour un quart d'heure
bonsoir monsieur harlem désir contre
monsieur duhamel
or alors vous n'êtes pas candidat aux
élections présidentielles
alors on va essayer avant de venir vite
à l'essentiel c'est à dire à ce qui
touche au racisme et aux relations entre
france et immigrés on va essayer d'abord
de lever brièvement quelques hypothèques
et de vous faire vous définir
politiquement pour piller les cartes sur
table et que les choses soient bien
claires
bon alors est ce que vous vous
considérez comme un homme politique ou
bien comme un homme public ou bien comme
une vedette ou bien comme une star ou
bien comme un intellectuel engagé ou
bien comme un militant comme quoi
comment est ce que vous vous définissez
d'abord je ne suis pas un homme
politique je ne fais pas partie d'un
parti politique je suis un jeune qui
avec d'autres jeunes fondé une
association sos racisme pour réagir à la
montée du racisme à la banalisation du
racisme
au départ nous étions quinze quelques
mois après à la concorde nous étions 400
milles
il y avait 300 comités qui s'étaient
créés dans toute la france je suis le
président de cette association et j'en
suis devenu un petit peu le porte parole
et c'est pour ça que j'ai accès aux
médias et que les gens me connaissent
vous êtes à un permanent de la vie
publique
je suis quelqu'un qui m'engagent
effectivement pour mes idées qui
m'engage en permanence parce que ce sont
des problèmes team concerts etc sont les
problèmes qui concernent l'avenir de mon
pays
vous êtes membre du parti socialiste ou
pas non je ne suis membre d'aucun parti
politique dont je ne suis pas membre du
parti social ce serait un déshonneur en
est membre du parti socialiste
pas du tout il ya des tas de gens très
bien qui se remonte du parti socialiste
j'assume persuadé et je n'ai jamais été
membre d'aucun parti ps que vous pensez
qu'on peut avoir un rôle du genre
d'animation d'un mouvement comme le
vôtre en ayant en même temps une
appartenance politique justement à
travers une carte d'un parti ou pas et
bien entendu moi je crois que les gens
qui s'engagent dans des partis
politiques
il est bon qu'il s'engage aussi s'ils le
souhaitent dans des mouvements
humanitaires dans des mouvements de
défense des droits de l'homme je crois
que ça n'est pas incompatible
mais il ne faut pas qu'ils oublient que
au sein de ses mouvements
eh bien ils doivent une certaine façon
laisser leur carte à l'entrée et puis
respecter l'indépendance de ces
mouvements alors vous n'êtes pas membre
du parti socialiste
est ce que vous vous considérez comme
appartenant disons à la famille
socialiste ou à la mouvance de
socialiste est ce que vous considérez
comme un compagnon de route
absolument pas je vous ai expliqué que
arc s'est pas c'est pas la même chose
que la demande d'un parti et on peut
être un sympathisant sans être membre
d'un parti c'est pas intervient je ne me
considère pas comme un membre d'une
mouvance quelconque ma mouvances à moi
ce serait l'humanisme c'est la
philosophie des droits de l'homme et
puis c'est surtout d'essayer
concrètement sur des points précis dans
la vie quotidienne de changer les choses
de faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait plus et
violences racistes qu'il n'y est plus et
intolérance et que l'intégration des
immigrés ceux d'aujourd'hui comme ceux
d'hier dans la société française puisse
se faire alors quand on dit quand on lui
en arctique beaucoup d'articles dans
cette émission
quand on lit que autour de vous ou vos
proches vos conseillers vos amis les
intellectuels connus qui vous ont pas
trop n'est que patronne et votre
mouvement étaient eux en général de
sympathies socialistes c'est vrai ou
c'est faux ça vous savez les gens qu'on
a vu autour de sos racisme qu'on les
connaît il ya tous les parrains qui ont
aidé à lancer le mouvement il y avait
coluche simone signoret balavoine il y a
les intellectuels il ya bernard henri
lévy à marek halter
mais il ya également de reyff rossard
qui a participé à notre dernier colloque
à la sorbonne andré frossard je crois
pas qu'on puisse dire que c'est un
affilié du parti socialiste il est
éditorialiste au figaro c'est un
académicien
il y à tout un tas de gens qui connu ou
non connus de droite ou de gauche engagé
politiquement ou non et signe que c'est
un problème dans la société française
que la france c'est le pays des droits
de l'homme que vivre avec des gens
d'origines différentes
c'est possible c'est une richesse et que
donc eh bien on peut s'engager et
soutenir l'action de sos racisme alors
dernière question là dessus et ensuite
on en vient à un sujet de fond derrière
quatre sont là dessus aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le début d'une carrière
politique et donc vous n'envisagez pas
une carrière politique vous moi je n'ai
absolument aucune ambition shannon au
stade de votre vie dans un autre stade
de ma vie moi comme l'a dit françois
henri de virieu j'étais étudiant et j'ai
interrompu provisoirement pour m'occuper
de sos racisme
j'ai eu l'occasion par ailleurs de
publier un livre de faire un certain
nombre d'études également pour revivre
évidemment mais mon souhait c'est de
devenir enseignant chercheur c'est ce à
quoi je me destinais et c'est cela ma
vocation
alors la france est un pays raciste à la
france n'est pas un pays raciste
la france c'est le pays des droits de
l'homme la france est un pays où dans
cette période de crise que nous vivons
crise la plus profonde depuis la
deuxième guerre mondiale et bien il y a
des gens qui se lèvent et qui disent moi
j'ai des explications simples si ça va
pas c'est la faute aux autres et qui
exploitent ces difficultés et donc on
voit ressurgir effectivement les
problèmes de racisme
donc la france est un pays où il ya des
problèmes de racisme et est ce que votre
connaissance
enfin après tout c'est votre sujet est
ce que votre connaissance la france des
réactions en ce moment plus racistes que
les pays voisins se trouvant dans la
même situation c'est à dire affrontant
la crise d' insécurité etc
vous savez j'ai eu l'occasion d'aller en
angleterre et en angleterre
et bien la situation est dramatique
parce que là bas il y a des quartiers
dans lesquels vivent les immigrés
jamaïcain des quartiers dans lesquels
vivent les immigrés pakistanais et puis
des quartiers dans lesquels vivent les
britanniques blanc et on assiste au
développement non seulement de ghettos
mais de véritables affrontements entre
les différentes communautés il n'y a pas
de brassage il n'y a pas ce phénomène
très important en france dont nous
bénéficions qui est le mélange des
jeunes de toutes origines dans les
écoles parce qu'il ya des écoles qui
correspondent à ces quartiers donc je
crois que ces problèmes
aujourd'hui ils sont vécues dans toute
la communauté européenne il y à 13
millions d'immigrés dans l'ensemble de
la communauté européenne
il y a eu des réponses et des attitudes
différentes selon les pays
je pense que si l'on fait un tableau
bien on s'aperçoit qu'il ya des choses
dont il ne faut surtout pas s'inspirer
c'est justement ce qui se passe en
angleterre avec les ghettos c'est ce qui
s'est passé en allemagne avec le
traitement des turcs
et puis il ya peut-être d'autres idées
dont on peut s'inspirer de choc des
choses qui ont été faites dans certaines
villes françaises des choses qui ont été
faites dans d'autres pays européens
en ce moment vous considérez j'imagine
puisque votre mouvement s'appelle sos
racisme vous considérer qu'en ce moment
il ya des risques particuliers de
racisme et même qui a en france un accès
de racisme ou pas écoutés depuis
quelques années vous le savez très bien
un lien au sol quand ce n'est pas le
problème c'est ce que vous pouvez c'est
ce que je pense en tout cas je pense
qu'il ya en france un problème de
racisme
pourquoi avons-nous créé sos racisme à
la fin de l'année 1984 souvenez vous il
y avait eu ce qu'on avait appelé le
train d'enfer
un jeune algérien qui avait été
défenestré il y avait eu ce jeune garçon
qui s'appelait toufik à la courneuve
cité des 4000
en seine saint denis et qui avaient été
tués il y avait eu une succession
d'agressions
non ça c'était pas après un concert
c'était à l'occasion d'un été chaud
comme on
il y avait eu cette succession
d'agressions dans l'indifférence on
avait l'impression que les immigrés
devaient payer leur tribut à la crise
économique que c'était une fatalité le
racisme et nous nous avons voulu montrer
que ça n'était pas une fatalité il ya
des points sur lesquels on a obtenu des
résultats
et puis il ya des points sur lesquels on
aimerait que ça aille plus vite mais
j'ai vraiment le sentiment que votre
génération y les plus sensibles et que
votre génération se mobilisent plus
facilement et que votre génération
regarde les choses disons de façon plus
saine selon vos critères que la
génération d'avant
mais des gens qui ont lutté contre le
racisme il y en a eu dans toutes les
générations les jeunes d'aujourd'hui ils
grandissent ensemble français et
immigrés donc ça leur semble naturel de
vivre dans une société de diversité et
je crois qu'effectivement la jeunesse a
entraîné un mouvement d'opinion qui
aujourd'hui va bien au delà de la jeanne
est à la dernière fête au concert nous
avons organisé à l'esplanade de
vincennes nous nous sommes aperçus que
vers 9h30 10h c'était les familles qui
arrivait au concert de sos racisme c'est
à dire le pape a le même la maman avec
le landau le petit frère la grande soeur
et je crois que ça c'est important les
enfants ont fait rentrer le badge à la
maison et aujourd'hui la lutte contre le
racisme l'idée que la solidarité entre
français et immigrés l'intégration ça
peut marcher c'est une idée qui progrès
et si vous me le permettez je peux même
vous citer un chiffre je crois qui est
plutôt encourageant
en 1985 la sofres avait demandé aux
français d'après vous faut-il renvoyer
un grand nombre de travailleurs immigrés
dans leur pays bien à l'époque la
réponse était de 25% il y avait 25 % de
gens qui disaient oui il faut renvoyer
un grand nombre de travailleurs immigrés
dans leur pays
on a reposé la question c'est l'ifop
cette fois en 1987 et la réponse c'est
10% de gens qui disent oui c'est à dire
moins de la moitié des gens donc je
crois qu'il y à un progrès qui a été
fait est alors intéressant pendant que
vous avez cette discussion de voir ce
que les français qui nous écoutent pense
d'eux
de leur comportement et de l'ordre et de
leur attitude raciste
on pose la question nous avez dit la
france n'est pas un pays raciste pays
qui a des problèmes de racisme on a posé
la question pendant que vous parliez le
racisme est il en france ce phénomène
très répandu
ah si répandu peu répandu pas du tout
répondu pas du tout répandu seulement 1
% ça vous étonnera pas les gens sont
assez lucide phénomène très répandu 23%
assez répandu 51% peu répandu 20% donc
assez répandue est peu répandu ça fait
quand même
71% des gens qui pensent qu'il y a en
france une présence du racisme et que ça
pose un problème et je constate
d'ailleurs que dans un sondage greening
dents parmi ceux qui disent très ou
assez
moi je dirais que c'est un problème
assez répandue je dirais que ça n'est
pas la généralité qui l'y a heureusement
des gens qui sont totalement dépourvus
de racisme qui sont tout à fait ouvert à
la différence mais qu'il ya un certain
nombre d'autres endroits où c'est plus
compliqué alors à avant d'en avant d'en
venir à des questions plus précises
concernant les relations entre français
et immigrés je vais vous poser une
question politique liée à ça comment est
ce que vous expliquez que en france plus
que dans les pays comparables sur plus
que dans les autres pays de la
communauté européenne
il ya une extrême droite qui aujourd'hui
représente à peu près 10% des français
ce qui n'est vrai né en espagne au
portugal et en italie ni en allemagne en
bretagne
comment est ce que vous expliquez ça eh
bien écoutez d'abord je ne suis pas
certain que dans les pays vous avez
cités on n'assiste pas progressivement à
la montée de phénomènes d'extrême droite
comparable au front national
vous savez qu'en angleterre il ya eu le
national fronte avec un député aussi qui
s'appelait enoch powell et qui avait une
influence tout à fait comparable à celle
de monsieur le pen
vous savez qu'il y avait eu l'équivalent
du géant manière vous savez qu'il ya en
bavière des phénomènes de démagogie et
d'exploitation des différences des
problèmes de l'immigration et du sida
qui sont très comparables à ce qui se
passe en france et par conséquent je
crois que il faut il faut comprendre que
tous les pays européens étant touchés
par la crise et où les pays européens
ayant fait appel massivement à
l'immigration au moment où il en avait
besoin et n'ayant pas intégrer les
immigrés risque d'être confronté à ce
problème maintenant pour ce qui est du
front national en france il faut
comprendre le phénomène surtout pour ce
qui est de la spécificité ça représente
parce que ce que vous d'exhaler vrai sur
la grande bretagne
mc c'est vrai il n'empêche que c'est en
france que le nombre d'électeurs qui
votent en sa faveur et le plus élevé
donc c'est une originalité vraiment ce
que vous l'expliqué cette originalité
alors écouter à mon avis dans le
phénomène de l'extrême droite en france
il faut distinguer trois choses vous
avez d'une part les fanatiques les vrais
extrémistes qui sont ultra minorité mais
qui sont des gens qui eux savent où ils
veulent en venir sont des gens qui
votent d'ailleurs ont des liens avec les
néo nazis en allemagne avec les
franquistes en espagne avec les
néofascistes du msi en italie bien ces
gens-là essayent d'exploiter la
situation et ils ont une idéologie très
clair c'est une minorité deuxièmement
vous avez les nostalgiques les
nostalgiques de la guerre d'algérie de
la guerre d'indochine
les gens qui ont été traumatisés par ces
périodes de l'histoire et qui n'ont pas
forcément réussi à les dépasser
et puis troisièmement vous avez monsieur
x des quartiers nord de marseille
les grandes cités qui ont été laissés à
l'abandon dont le fils est au chômage
dont la volée l'autoradio dont la boîte
aux lettres a été arraché et lorsque ce
monsieur est arrivé au 8e étage chez lui
et qui se rend compte qu'il a oublié le
sel eh bien ils obligés de redescendre
par l'escalier parce que l'ascenseur est
en panne et que personne ne s'en le cul
et de passer dans le hall au milieu
d'une haie de jeunes désoeuvrés qui sont
au chômage dont une grande partie
d'immigrés et qui lui semble
effectivement menaçant alors ce monsieur
vote pour le front national bien ça sert
à rien de hurler le pen le pen il faut
commencer par réparer l'ascenseur il
faut comprendre que si le front national
progresse c'est pas grâce au talent
personnel de monsieur le pen mais c'est
simplement parce qu'ils prospèrent sur
les insuffisances de la société
française et c'est à ces insuffisances
qu'il faut s'en prendre
alors justement ça me mène exactement la
question que je voulais vous poser les
problèmes de cohabitation entre
communautés différentes se pose existe
d'abord justement non pas dans les
quartiers chics mais dans les quartiers
populaires pourquoi 1 est ce que ça se
pose apparemment statistiquement plus en
france que dans d'autres pays c'est pas
une évidence parce que les ascenseurs
fonctionnent pas mieux dans les pays d'à
côté bon pourquoi plus en france
qu'ailleurs
et puis d'autre part en dehors de la
réparation des ascenseurs tout le monde
sera d'accord avec vous pour réparer les
ascenseurs oui mais important parce que
jamais à la télévision message du hamel
tu as fait d'accord
oui mais en dehors du vendeur sur les
ascenseurs qui est important je suis
d'accord avec vous qui est important
mais qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
pratiquement qui changent les choses
parce que vous le dites vous-même vous
dites c'est lié à l'insécurité et à
l'image de la sécurité où c'est lié au
cheval serra se sont pas des choses
qu'on peut modifier en 30 secondes ça
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
concrètement
vous avez parfaitement raison moi
d'abord je voudrais vous expliquer
comment secret cette situation où des
gens on arrive à adhérer à un discours
démagogique ou on dit que si ça va pas
c'est la faute aux autres
c'est la faute aux immigrés bien comment
on fait un ghetto par exemple la prenons
l'exemple des minguettes les minguettes
il ya quelques années personne ne
voulait y aller pourquoi c'était un
quartier de 35000 habitants laissé à
l'abandon
1 dans la banlieue de lyon qu'on avait
construit à la va vite en faisant les
immeubles les uns en face des autres
parce qu'on le faisait avec une seule
grue et que c'était plus simple que de
déplacer la grue bien où on n'avait pas
entretenu l'ensemble des équipements
collectifs les chauffages qui tombait en
panne des ascenseurs qui était en panne
il n'y avait pas d'accueil pour les
jeunes alors tout le monde essayait de
fuir ce quartier qui pouvaient fuir ce
quartier les gens qui avaient des
ressources suffisantes bien et qu'ils
pouvaient accéder à un loyer plus élevé
par exemple dans le centre de lyon mais
aujourd'hui dans le centre de lyon comme
d'ailleurs dans le centre de paris
vous savez très bien que les loyers ont
augmenté d'au moins 30% cette année ci
ont demandé à tous les gens qui ont une
augmentation de 30% d'appeler jean louis
le sel asvp il deviendrait souvent une
minute bien alors donc ceux qui
restaient dans ces quartiers comme les
minguettes
ce sont les gens qui tout simplement été
des gens de milieux défavorisés et en
particulier les immigrés et ces gens là
il détestait le cadre de vie dans lequel
il était d accord là c'est facile
d'exploiter leurs problèmes et de leur
dire ça et bien moi j'ai une solution
c'est de s'en prendre aux inhalations
les racines mes solutions concrètes à
voir solution on ne va pas polémiquer de
polémiquer sur le fait de savoir s'il ya
eu 30 % en augmentation en un an dans
tous les quartiers centraux des grandes
villes sur le problème qui nous
intéresse pourrait faire l'expérience
mais je voudrais pas renier pour lui la
scène mais pour ce qui est des
minguettes et bien écoutez depuis 1986
et pour la première fois dans l'histoire
de ce quartier il y a plus de gens qui
ont demandé à venir y habiter que de
gens qui ont cherché à fuir le quartier
de thouars communauté de toute
communauté et notamment
des français comme on dit de souche
c'est à dire généralement dans cette
région de lyon des français d'origine
italienne notamment et bien pour quelle
raison parce que on s'est occupé du
problème parce qu'on a arrêté de laisser
à l'abandon ce quartier des minguettes
on a d'abord détruit un certain nombre
de tours on recrée en ce qui est bien
content c'est à la fois l'office hlm la
communauté urbaine de lyon la
municipalité et l'état et la région
c'est à dire un ensemble de partenaires
qui d'ailleurs sont de couleurs
politiques différentes et qui se sont
dit que c'était quand même pas une
situation acceptable socialement
c'était une situation qui provoque et en
plus une recrudescence de délinquance et
qui du point de vue financier était une
aberration car il y avait une dizaine de
tours qui étaient murées c'est à dire
une dizaine de tours où personne ne
payait le loyer il y avait de plus en
plus de logements vides
il ya aujourd'hui en france trente-huit
mille logements hlm qui sont vides on
est dans une période de crise du
logement
il ya des jeunes ménages qui cherche où
habitait et il ya trente-huit mille
logements qui sont ville où personne ne
veut aller alors pourquoi les minguettes
maintenant ça marche
oui et bien parce que deux mots parce
que joue à la session et bien tout
simplement s'est occupé du chauffage on
s'est occupé des cloisons roi de
l'isolément phonique et de l'isolément
thermique on s'est occupé des espaces
communs on s'est occupé des boîtes aux
lettres
on a mis des interphones on a créé pour
les jeunes des équipements sportives et
des stars mondiales auraient accès
recentrerait un anti-modèle minguettes
il ya un modèle minguettes maintenant
probablement et je crois que
effectivement il ya un modèle minguettes
comme il y à un modèle du sillon de
bretagne à côté nantes qui était un
bâtiment qu'on voulait détruire à la fin
des années 70 parce qu'il y avait deux
tiers des logements qui était vide et
que aujourd'hui au contraire c'est un
endroit qui est prise et on a développé
aussi des commerces de proximité et je
crois que tout cela ce sont des idées
des propositions qui doit fonctionner
d'ailleurs je vous donne juste une
information sais que dans les semaines
qui vont venir à la rentrée nous allons
publier une brochure qui fera état de
toutes ces expériences réussies et des
propositions qui pourraient être
appliqués dans l'ensemble des quartiers
qui sont laissées à l'abandon et qui
permettrait avec un souci de réalisme
gestionnaire c'est à dire en ayant le
souci d'avoir un budget qui s'équilibre
sur un certain temps et bien de
réhabiliter ces quartiers et donc de
créer des conditions de relations entre
les français les immigrés qu'ils soient
plus acceptable trois questions très
ponctuel pour que vous puissiez y
répondre brièvement et que sa libération
leurs pertes et que ça ne modifie pas
l'horaire de françois henri de virieu
alors première les horreurs de
téléspectateurs ok le nôtre et notre
absolument premièrement est ce que vous
êtes favorables ou hostiles à ce que les
immigrés en france donc qui n'ont pas la
société française mais qui travaillent
en france ou qui voudraient travailler
puissent voter aux élections municipales
comme ça se fait au pays alors qu'en
alsace suède en p2 pays et comme il est
question que ça se passe maintenant dans
un land en allemagne moi personnellement
j'y suis favorable mais je pense qu'il
faut d'abord convaincre tous les
français que c'est une mesure qui va
optimiser l'intégration et qui ne faut
surtout pas essayer de faire passer ça à
coups de 49 3 je crois que dans le
domaine de la lutte contre le racisme
on a besoin d'un consensus il faut
convaincre tout le monde les gens de
droite comme les gens de gauche
alors pourquoi j'y suis favorable bien
d'abord parce que les immigrés qui
vivent dans une commune je crois qu'il
faut tout faire pour qu'il se sente
attaché à cette commune et pour qu'il se
sente responsabilisé par les problèmes
de la commune
or ces immigrés ils sont soumis aux
mêmes devoirs que les autres habitants
ils payent les impôts locaux qui
contribuent au budget de la commune et
ils sont concernés par les mêmes
problèmes par exemple le fait
d'installer ou non une crèche le fait de
construire ou non une piscine bien je
pense que ce serait une bonne chose
effectivement que ces immigrés comme
c'est le cas hollande comme c'est le cas
en suède comme c'est le cas au danemark
comme c'est le cas dans certains cantons
helvétiques en suisse puissent
participer aux élections locales
alors moi je crois qu'il faut d'abord
faire l'expérience en france pour
essayer de convaincre les gens il ya une
ville mons en baroeul où on a donné un
droit de vote consultatif aux immigrés
ils ont envoyé des représentants qui ont
une voix consultative au xixè grâce à
moi je suis pour que dans un premier
temps on généralise ce système de la
représentation consultative on attend un
certain temps on fait le bilan et si ça
marche je suis sûr que la majorité des
français sont favorables à une réforme
constitutionnelle qui permettrait de
donner aux immigrés cette possibilité
d'être des citoyens de la ville de
participer à la vie civique alors plus
brièvement deux questions encore donc
sur les immigrés des français quentin
immigrés entre en france de façon
clandestine
on expulse est la règle c'est la loi est
ce que ça vous paraît relever du racisme
d'expulser un immigré en situation
irrégulière moi je suis contre
l'immigration clandestine
je suis pour que les immigrés est un
statut un titre de séjour et de travail
légal et qui leur assure une véritable
situation dans la société française mais
il ya rarement des immigrés qui entre
irrégulièrement alors clandestinement
elle vous avez parquet ce qu'en raison
ménard croit revoir fait qu'est ce que
vous préconisez conan voilà alors pour
ce qui est des expulsions elles doivent
être faites avec toutes les garanties du
droit c'est à dire que lorsqu'on
soupçonne quelqu'un d'être en situation
irrégulière eh bien il doit avoir le
droit de se défendre devant la justice
avec un avocat
le problème de la procédure actuelle
c'est qu'on l'a transféré de la justice
qui s'occupait autrefois de ses
problèmes à la police et aux préfectures
le pouvoir d'expulsion donc les gens
sont arrêtés par la police on contrôler
leurs papiers on estime qu'ils ne sont
pas valables ou qu'ils n'en n'ont pas et
on les expulse sans qu'à aucun moment il
n'est un road book maintenant et nous
sommes le seul pays d'europe
monsieur duhamel ça c'est important où
le recours n'est pas suspensif r si
l'immigré dit vous vous trompez pas lui
dire on nous expulse d'abord et vous
ferez le recours au conseil d'état après
donc que vous préconisez qu'on en vienne
à l'autre solution qui est elle est
appliquée dans le reste de l'europe et
qui consiste dans ces cas là quand on
les arrête à les mettre en prison et
ensuite à examiner le point de savoir si
oui ou non il était en situation
régulière
non mais de toute façon en france on
l'aimé quand même en prison avant de les
expulser
oui mais pas longtemps donc ça n'a rien
à lui voit pas une question d'âge
chapelet question la wii non pas du tout
c'était la deuxième elle m'a redonné moi
je voudrais juste dire une dernière
chose le l'immigration clandestine
si vous me le permettez sur
l'immigration clandestine et parce qu'il
ya aussi une grande hypocrisie pour ce
qui est des délinquants qui viennent en
france pour faire des trafics m'ont bien
ils doivent être jugés les devoirs sont
les mêmes pour tous et puis expulsé ça
il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté
mais alors moi j'ai été dans la région
d'avignon ya pas très longtemps au mois
de mai j'ai été invité pour des réunions
ce monsieur un petit peu informés et on
m'a dit là-bas que si les immigrés
clandestins qui viennent faire le
travail saisonnier pour ramasser les
pommes n'était pas là et bien le prix
des pommes d'avignon serait multiplié
par deux parce que les immigrés
clandestins
on les paye pas au smic et on paye pas
de charges sociales si le prix des
pommes été multiplié par deux et bien ce
serait pas les pommes d'avignon qui
serait vendue à rungis et il y à des
secteurs entiers
on les attendait cette importance à ce
que tu attends viennent des villes
françaises pour poser la question à la
très grande hypocrisie dans la façon
dont tout le monde parle de
l'immigration clandestine
il ya des secteurs entiers
de l'économie du bâtiment du textile de
l'agriculture qui vivent de ces
travailleurs clandestins
alors moi je suis pour que l'on
légaliser que l'on régularisent la
situation de ces gens qui apportent une
contribution à l'économie française
qu'on arrête de l'est sur exploités dans
des conditions de sécurité et de
rémunérations qui sont indécentes
et puis qu'ensuite et bien il y ait une
véritable politique des flux c'est à
dire que on décide éventuellement que on
intègre les immigrés qui sont là et
qu'on n'a pas la possibilité en raison
de la situation économique d'ouvrir
davantage les frontières parce que ce
serait donner aux gens des illusions sur
la capacité de résoudre leurs problèmes
nous dérivons dangereusement comme des
rendez vous merci merci alain duhamel de
2,2 questions posées pendant que vous
parliez parts et les sondages svp la
première a trait le pet à le pen
pensez-vous en ce qui concerne les
propos de le pen sur l'immigration
pensez vous que il dit tout haut ce que
beaucoup de français pensent tout bas
46% des gens pensent que oui et qu'il
tient des propos inacceptables et
caricaturait entièrement la réalité 49%
deuxième chose vous avez vous avez dit
favorable à l'intégration des immigrés
question que nous avons posée la plupart
des immigrés passés où la plupart des
immigrés -pour on est intégré que c'est
uniquement une question de temps par les
opinions des français sont très partagés
43% pensent que l'intégration est
possible pour la plupart des immigrés et
ne pourront pas être intégrés toujours
la plupart car la société française est
trop différente de la leur
39% mais écoutez ça c'est très très
intéressant les jokers parce que vous
savez on a posé la question aussi de
savoir si un juif est aussi français
qu'un autre français est un institut de
sondage qui a posé cette question cette
année il ya 85 % des gens ont envoyé une
immense majorité quand même sillon qui
ont répondu oui un juif est aussi
français qu'un autre français est bien
savez vous combien de gens pensaient
qu'un juif est aussi français qu'un
autre français en 1966 60% et en 1946
après la guerre il n'y avait que 37% des
gens qui pensaient qu'un juif est aussi
français qu'un
autre français donc vous voyez que
l'intégration se promener à 100 de
remonter bien l'intégration voyez ça
prend du temps ça prend du temps et ça
marche qu'on s'en occupe
parce que il a fallu pour ça qu'on lutte
contre l'antisémitisme et que
effectivement on lutte aussi pour faire
admettre aux gens qu'on pouvait avoir
une religion différente une identité
différente et être quand même un
français comme les autres
et bien aujourd'hui quand on demande aux
gens est ce que vous pensez qu'un beurre
c'est à dire un enfant arabe de la
deuxième génération qui vit en france
qui est né en france
est ce que vous pensez qu'il peut être
qu'il est aussi français qu'un autre les
gens répondent oui à 78%
donc c'est quand même assez encourageant
mais comme je les dis nous vivons une
période de chômage
une période de difficultés ou si on ne
s'occupe pas des choses et bien on peut
assister au développement des violence
et de l'intolérance
svp autres questions des téléspectateurs
oui d'où proviennent les fonds de sos
racisme combien le gouvernement
socialiste vous at il donné idem pour le
gouvernement chirac alors les fonds de
sos racisme
eh bien ils proviennent d'abord des
adhésions puisque c'est une association
et il y a donc quinze mille adhérents
dans les 300 comités de sos racisme qui
sont répartis dans toute la france des
cotisations de courir la cotisation est
de 100 francs
mais on accepte des cotisations de 50 ou
30 francs pour les gens qui sont au
chômage pour les étudiants et pour les
lycéens et d'ailleurs vous êtes tous
appelés à envoyer vos dons ou à adhérer
si vous n'avez pas encore fait
deuxièmement il ya les donne à 17h aussi
ya les membres bienfaiteurs les
donateurs qui sont au nombre de 35
milles qui sont pour une grande part des
parents d'ailleurs des adhérents de sos
racisme qui ne portait pas le badge
directement ne participait pas aux
activités du mouvement mais soutenait
ainsi l'engagement de leurs enfants
il ya tous les artistes que vous
connaissez que vous avez vu au côté de
sos racisme tous les intellectuels sont
ici exactement ces artistes d'ailleurs
nous leur demandons régulièrement de
donner des concerts au profit de sos
racisme ou de donner la recette d'un de
leurs concerts
c'est ce qu'ont fait des gens comme jean
jacques goldman francis cabrel les
musiciens africains mory kanté jacques
higelin etc
et puis alors il y a eu effectivement
les subventions alors il ya eu des
subventions du gouvernement de gauche
comme du gouvernement de droite je mets
plus de goût
du gauche que de droite cercle
gouvernement de droite il a arrêté plus
vite pour des raisons que j'ignore parce
que nous n'avons pas changé
sos racisme nous sommes toujours pareil
la petite main c'est toujours la même le
discours que nous tenons c'est toujours
le même et il ya un certain nombre de
gens comme eux bon claude malhuret
philippe seguin qui nous ont donné des
subventions pour faire le concert de la
bastille en juin 1986 et puis ensuite
ils ont arrêté alors remarqué ça nous a
appris à nous débrouiller tout seul et
le dernier concert de sos racisme celui
de l'esplanade de vincennes eh bien nous
l'avons fait uniquement en vendant les
droits de télévision
la retransmission à la fois sur une
chaîne française et sur des chaînes en
italie en échange une chaîne dont il
faut rappeler que c'était là c'est un
monsieur robert hersant
oui mais nous nous avons vendu les
droits à monsieur berlusconi mais qui
travaillent là quand même avec ossuaire
sens oui mais l'intérêt c'était que
monsieur berlusconi il est aussi dans
canal 5 en italie dans une chaîne en
espagne dans une chaîne en allemagne et
donc on a pu vendre les droits plus cher
parce que c'était pour plusieurs
télévisions
et puis alors oui ça a été les la letr
du point de vue de la diffusion de votre
message tout à fait parce que ça nous a
fait connaître dans des pays où nous
sommes pas encore installé puis aussi
dans des pays où nous sommes déjà
installés comme l'allemagne mais où ça
nous permet de développer le mouvement
et puis par ailleurs et bien nous avons
vendu des espaces publicitaires des
vignettes de soutien et nous avons vendu
également vous savez des boissons des
sandwichs et comme ça on a pu équilibrer
le budget de la fête de sos racisme sans
subvention une autre question genre
wilson vous même désir combien touche et
vous par mois alors comme je l'expliqué
tout à l'heure alain duhamel depuis que
j'ai interrompu mes études pour
m'engager dans ce combat et souhaitera 6
j'ai publié un livre donc j'ai touché
les droits d'auteur j'ai fait valoir mes
compétences universitaires mais
diplomatique mais mes connaissances dans
le domaine de l'insertion des jeunes
pour faire un certain nombre d'études et
de contrats auprès d'organismes qui
s'occupe de cela et donc je touche
environ 8500 francs par mois
voilà bien d'études et aux rôles de plus
de savoir que je laisse de côté le
salaire de mon épouse qui évidemment med
très bien bon je pense me satisfait jean
louis la scène henri amouroux pour un
quart d'heure
bonsoir monsieur amouroux jean-philippe
plaisir mais monsieur amour gicquel sûr
je ne voudrais pas vous mais moi il
m'appelle claude djakus village vous
appeler monsieur henri claude jacques
hugon
ce serait très drôle remarquer qu on
s'appelle tous par tous nos par une ode
au prénom c'est ce que je voulais la
journée 5 vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
de réparer d'ascenseur vous avez tout à
fait raison
réparer l'ascenseur ça veut dire aussi
quelquefois parler vrai oui tout à fait
nous sommes d'accord et bien entendu
vous savez je dis rien n'est décidé
assure aller moi j'ai deux petites
questions à vous poser pendant deux
jours et demi tous les français ont
entendu parler de châteauroux
toutes les émissions tout le temps dans
tous les journaux
je vais vous poser deux questions que je
vais pouvoir répondre très simplement
combien de maghrébins blessés et combien
de dégâts là combien sont estimer les
dégâts au restaurant le pub qui était le
restaurant attaquer écoutez moi je ne
sais pas à combien s'élèvent les dégâts
qui ont fait suite à cet incident et je
crois qu'effectivement et vous avez
raison de le rappeler ce qui est
dramatique c'est ce qui aidera mais
attendez oui excusez moi d'ouvrir
déplacement à votre combien de blessés
il ya eu pas ruminer maghrébins oui il
ya eu plusieurs blessés à ma
connaissance il ya eu au moins trois
blessés
et combien de dégâts au café vous savez
je ne suis pas les armes et là si
j'avais 10 ans mais je vais vous dire
oui bien entendu
je vais vous dire pourquoi parce que je
trouve qu'il faut employer les mots
qu'il faut quand il faut et j'ai
téléphoné depuis deux jours j'ai
téléphoné plusieurs fois par jour à
châteauroux il se trouve que c'est une
ville que je connais très bien
j'ai téléphoné à la mairie le maire
n'est pas là d'ailleurs monsieur bernard
dette en vacances mais lisse et son
premier adjoint chrono va rencontrer qui
est évident en liaison avec le maire et
le maire âgé de l'été de se renier et
j'ai téléphoné à quelques prévention à
ce que je veux dire qu'en parler parler
pendant deux jours et demi d'une
histoire aussi mince lorsque le premier
adjoint me dit monsieur
vu aucun dégât et lorsque le directeur
du café monsieur michel je demande
d'ailleurs il habite place de la
république
et si les castelroussins téléphone alors
là aussi le téléphone sera surencombré
monsieur rioux s'est passé de la presse
que vous faites et c'est le procès
intenté à temps des châteaux mais pas du
tout le procès de la façon dont la
presse traite la photo on la presse donc
tout soit clair sos racisme aussi et
nommera également qui fait un communiqué
disant que ça rappelle le début des
sections d'assaut la naissance des
sections dation au moment du nazisme au
début du nazisme c'est à dire qu'il y a
des choses graves dont il faut parler
avec gravité et que dans cette affaire
on parle avec abondance d'un incident
tout à fait mineurs car lorsque vous
téléphonez si vous aviez téléphoné au
directeur du café vous aurais dit
monsieur il s'est rien passé du tout il
s'est rien passé l'amour explique
majorité à nevers très bien merci
alors écoutez nous avons envoyé un
membre du bureau national de sos racisme
qui responsable justement des relations
avec la province et bien je peux pas
être partout en france
à tout moment et alors je vais vous dire
vous estimez vous que ce qui s'est passé
n'est pas grave ça n'est ni le point de
vue du maire ni le point de vue de
l'évêque de châteauroux qui a fait une
déclaration et les évêques font pas des
déclarations tous les jours pour dire
que c'était très inquiétant ce qu'il y
avait dans la tête de ces jeunes vous
savez ce qui s'est passé quand ces
jeunes ont été interpellés par la police
ils ont dit deux choses la première
c'est on a fait ça parce qu'on n'aime
pas les arabes et la deuxième c'est
qu'il ne comprenait pas qu'on les
relâche pas et ils ont dit c'est parce
qu'il ya trop de juifs dans la police
est alors vous vous estimez que ça ça
n'est pas grave en france aujourd'hui
moi je crois que ça c'est dramatique en
france aujourd'hui je vais je vais vous
dire pour quelles raisons c'est
dramatique parce que la france c'est
justement le pays où on a la chance
d'avoir des jeunes qu'ils soient
antiracistes qui sont solidaires qui
sont les uns avec les autres et que par
contre en angleterre dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure où il ya le phénomène de
l'exclusion
eh bien on voit se développer ces bandes
de skinheads qui s'attaque aux immigrés
je voudrais pas moins que ça continue à
se développer en france et c'est pour
cette raison que le maire de châteauroux
qui n'est pas à la mairie mais avec qui
nous sommes en contact par le biais de
son premier as
joint que nous avons rencontré a accepté
de présider un comité de prévention du
racisme que nous allons mettre sur pied
avec lui dès la rentrée et nous allons
proposer une nouvelle que je vous donne
dans toutes les villes de france à tous
les maires qu'ils soient de droite ou de
gauche
châteauroux c'est une mairie de droite
ça change rien à tous les maires de
france de mettre sur pied des comités de
prévention du racisme comme on l'a mis
sur pied des comités de prévention de la
délinquance parce que il faut se
demander comment des jeunes qui ont
entre 14 et 23 ans
tout à coup dans la tête que pour
résoudre leurs problèmes il faut aller
casser la tête à un immigré à un arabe
ce que je voulais dire je l'a très bien
dit ce qu'il faut laisser aux choses
leur proportion autant je trouve
scandaleux et infruts least one is
innocent je suis je bouffe temps d'aller
affreux l'histoire de nice autant je
trouve qu évoqué c'est pas vous qui
l'avez fait d'ailleurs sais pas vous
mais qu évoqué la création des sections
d'assaut et le début du nazisme à propos
de ce qui s'est passé à châteauroux mais
bon ça c'est non seulement rab
c'est fort de proportion si vous êtes
d'accord monsieur amouroux vers mes
toiles je suis je suis d'accord avec
vous et permettez moi de vous faire une
remarque justement vous n'avez peut-être
pas remarqué mais sos racisme on n'a
jamais fait de déclarations fracassantes
contre la police ou contre tel ou tel
personnage nous je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué on a toujours le souci
d'apporter des solutions tu veux quand
lens a dit quoi jamais jamais je vous
mets au delà non vraiment et à chaque
fois qu'il ya eu des problèmes ou des
bavures et nous allons en parler
j'espère nous avons fait la
démonstration que s'il y avait eu une
bavure c'est peut-être parce qu'il y
avait des règles qui avaient pas été
respectées il fallait se demander
pourquoi ces règles n'étaient pas
respectés ou qui avait des règles qui
n'étaient pas bonnes et que peut-être on
pouvait changer ses règles
je prends juste un exemple à propos des
bavures vous savez en france au stand de
tir
les policiers gagne +2 points quand titi
rockeur et à la tête que quand il tire
dans les jambes pour une raison simple
c'est qu'il ya même pas de jambes dans
les cibles sur lesquelles ils
s'entraînent et donc qui gagne 20 points
à la tête et 20 points au coeur et bien
en allemagne et en rfa c'est le
contraire on a tous les points quand on
tire dans les jambes et on n'a aucun
point quand on tire à la tête et qu'en
tire au coeur voilà un exemple concret
ainsi une petite chose il faudrait
changer beaucoup d'autres petites choses
mais qui permettrait peut-être qu'il y
ait moins deux bavures ou qu'ils aient
moins deux bavures mortels ça c'est
voilà nous ce que nous disons on
n'essaye pas d'exploiter les problèmes
qui vont pas et de faire des
déclarations fracassantes
en tout cas il y a une chose également à
laquelle vous pourriez participer parce
que je pense nous sommes français tous
les deux oui moi je voulais vous voulez
comment l'amélioration de la situation
ce qui exaspère un peu les gens et je
les comprends un peu c'est que le losc
comme ça s'est passé à bordeaux par
exemple il ya un mois exactement un mois
lorsqu'un garçon est tuée de neuf coups
de couteau par deux maghrébins
on en parle absolument pas ah bon on ne
parle pas mais je vais vous dire moi ça
m'étonnerait qu'on n'en parle pas dans
tous les journaux parlent en parle dans
les journaux locaux dont on en parle
dans sud ouest
on parle pas je pense qu'ils se fassent
un certain nombre d'incidents je reçois
la presse de marseille je trouve
il ya vu par exemple ya quelques jours
un mois peu près un commissariat de
police qui est dans un quartier qui a
été attaqué par une salve certain nombre
de gens ça ne sort pas de des journaux
marseillais patrick meyer moi je vais
vous dire ça mais là il faudrait mais je
crois pas que l'appareil dentaire
dernière viol dans une colonie je vois
que l'économe agri mines et un nom à
consonance maghrébine on en parle on en
parle en dernière page et du monde est
prévue
la sers bien non mais je veux dire je
veux je veux dire monsieur mouche
voudrais vous dire je rejoint
châteauroux ou enfin vous pouvez
téléphoner on peut téléphoner à ce
patron de restaurant qui j'ai téléphoné
qui me dit monsieur ne pas casser un
verre monsieur on n'a pas renversé un
parasol et qui me dit toute ma famille
était en forme et je veux dire
simplement qu'il ne faut pas utiliser
les mots dans n'importe quelle
circonstance le mot racisme est un mot
très fort le mauvais sort s est un mot
très fort c'est le mot comme un emploi
quand un bateau coule
alors est-ce que la france coule c'est
ce que nous sommes menacés de couler
sous le poids du racisme mais la france
ne coule pas la france est un pays
formidable d'abord c'est le pays des
droits de l'homme
c'est un pays dans lequel on l'a montré
il ya une majorité de gens qui sont
inquiets de ce problème de la montée du
racisme ya un sondage récemment qui a
montré que pour deux tiers des français
le phénomène de l'extrême droite était
un danger pour la démocratie donc je
crois qu'au contraire la français est un
pays qui sait susciter des anticorps
contre les atteintes aux droits de
l'homme mais malheureusement il y à un
certain nombre de domaines gelé montrer
qu'on a laissé à l'abandon et c'est pour
ça que les relations entre français et
immigrés sont aussi difficiles et juste
pour terminer une petit show vous avez
évoqué le cas d'immigrés qui commettent
des actes de délinquance
et moi je suis très claire nous
demandons-nous l'égalité des droits mais
aussi l'égalité des devoirs et
l'immigration n'est pas une circonstance
atténuante
lorsqu'on commet un délit il est évident
que les immigrés et les français doivent
être égaux devant la justice et que ceux
qui font des bêtises mais ils doivent
être punis de la même façon je pense
qu'il est très important que vous le
disiez ce soir c'est très important mais
je vais vous dire s'il ya des gens qui
n'étaient pas convaincus que c'était
notre opinion et s'il ya des gens d'une
façon générale qui sont pas d'accord
avec nous c'est peut-être c'est vrai
parce que on sait pas c'est bien
expliqué et ça je suis d'accord avec
vous cette émission peut être l'occasion
de mieux faire comprendre le sens de
notre action est d'essayer de répondre
aux questions que les gens se posent sur
l'engagement de sos racisme
mais j'aimerais qu'il soit persuadé
d'une chose c'est que notre souci à nous
c'est d'apporter des solutions
c'est pas de dénoncer pour le plaisir de
dénoncer à propos d' apporter des
solutions avait vu l'émission il ya
mois et demi à peu près de serge blanco
c'était sur la troisième chaîne
non je suis désherbant vous savez c'est
un très grand joueur de rugby
oui je connais serge blanco pas
personnellement en bout j'ai suivi ses
exploits et on lui a parlé on lui a
parlé de sue est raciste il a dit mon
goût il sait très bien mais le sos
racisme ne fait pas d'actions sur le
terrain
et moi je préfère des gens comme lino
ventura ou comme jean luc lahaye qui je
crois ce soir dans la salle un qui fait
dans le squad
ils font des choses sur le terrain
beaucoup plus importante pour les
enfants pour les jeunes qui s'en
occupent davantage alors que faites-vous
sur le plan concret alors sur le plan
concret comme je voulais dit sos raciste
et 300 comités dans toute la france mais
dès le départ je vais vous expliquer
l'activité sos savez pour signification
le fait qu'on pouvait téléphoner à sos
racisme et que l'art si on avait été
victime d'une agression ou si on était
un petit peu isolé face à
l'administration et bien on trouverait
quelqu'un pour vous aider c'était ça le
sens premier de sos racisme et c'est
pour faire connaître cette activité que
l'on a été obligé de médiatiser le
mouvement je vais vous donner un exemple
concret de ce que nous avons fait cette
semaine
lundi il ya un jeune homme qui est venu
nous voir et un jeune homme antillais et
il travaille dans une société de
formation professionnelle y forme
d'autres jeunes pour qu'ils puissent
s'insérer dans des entreprises bien et
il se trouve qu'il a reçu à sa société
de formation professionnelle une lettre
envoyée par une entreprise qui lui dit
la chose suivante monsieur buffon
viendra comme convenu mercredi 6 août 86
nous lui avons demandé de vous faire de
notre part quelques observations en
particulier la présence dans le stage de
maghrébins et d'antillais alors que nous
vous avions demandé expressément de ne
pas en prévoir
alors voilà un cas concret de 72 et un
vif intérêt de racisme au quotidien
seulement les gens sont sont abandonnés
bien ils savent pas comment se
débrouiller face à des situations de
discrimination comme ça sont des jeunes
maghrébins et antillais qui suivent un
stage ils espèrent pouvoir aller
travailler dans une entreprise dont on
va pas citer le nom mais on pourrait le
faire et on leur dit non vous avez suivi
le stage vous avez la qualification mais
vous êtes antillais vous êtes maghrébins
donc on veut
vous alors nous intervenons d'abord
d'abord nous intervenons pour essayer
d'obtenir une conciliation auprès de
cette entreprise
d'autant que c'est signé du directeur
des relations humaines
alors on se dit si ceux-ci ce monsieur a
vraiment le sens des relations humaines
peut-être que on peut trouver une
solution et puis si on ne trouve pas de
solution mais nous faisons intervenir
nos avocats et nous avons une
cinquantaine de dossiers par semaine
il ya aussi des gens qui ont des
problèmes avec l'administration vous
savez comme c'est difficile même pour un
français parfois de traiter avec la
sécurité sociale ou de traiter avec les
impôts alors imaginez pour un immigré
qui n'a pas été accueillis quand il est
venu en france on n'a pas fait de cours
d'alphabétisation et qui arrive à peine
à comprendre les papiers qu'il a sous
les yeux
donc nous intervenons aussi sur ces
dossiers là voilà le travail concret de
sos racisme
je vous dirais que même si sur le reste
nous ne sommes pas compris et bien moi
je ne regretterai rien à ce que nous
avons fait uniquement pour les centaines
de gens que nous avons pu aider grâce à
nos avocats et grâce au dévouement des
étudiants en droit bénévoles qui
viennent faire avec nous la permanence
juridique d'ailleurs je lance aussi à
l'appel là parce que ils sont pas assez
nombreux et parfois les gens sont
obligés de faire la queue pendant une
demi journée pour pouvoir être reçus
vous avez dit dans playboy tout inconnu
l'éclectisme c'est quand on connaît le
christ que l'une des grandes chances de
la france c'était que l'immigration
soient disséminées ne soient pas
concentrés
or vous savez aussi bien que moi qu'elle
est concentré quand parlais tout à
l'heure duhamel parlé tout à l'heure de
monsieur le pen
pourquoi le front national 25% à
marseille et pourquoi le front national
5% à rennes
vous savez aussi pleinement la réponse
il ya vous avez sont bien que moins de
la réponse le promu l'immigration est
concentrée sur paris sur la région
parisienne l'île de france 40% et sur la
région rhône alpes
she will failla pas 40 % d'immigrés en
ile de france 1 non non non très très
loin de l'arbre d'entrée de concentrer
en deux grandes régions paris la région
parisienne je vais le rôle et le nord le
sud est et on peut citer des exemples
concrets
tout d'abord la france est effectivement
un pays où pour l'instant il n'y a
pratiquement pas de vrais ghetto c'est à
dire que même là où il ya une forte
concentration d'immigrés il reste quand
même un brassage important et vous
n'avez pas ce phénomène
ahurissant
des états unis ou en changeant de rue
vous passez d'un quartier où tous les
gens sont blancs un quartier où tous les
gens sont portoricains et ensuite à un
quartier où tous les gens sont noirs à
mardi à marseille alors les gens vous
diront qu'il commence à y avoir des
gains et c'est pour cette raison qu'ils
seraient peut-être largement temps de
s'occuper de ce qui se passe à marseille
mais moi je vais vous citer un exemple
dans la seine saint denis qui est le
département de france où il ya le plus
fort pourcentage d'immigrés et bien à
montfermeil 1 et à clichy sous bois il y
a entre 25 et 30 % d'immigrés au raincy
qui est une ville limitrophe juste à
côté de ces deux autres villes il y a 6
% d'immigrés
pourquoi est-ce qu ainsi il y a 6 %
d'immigrés parce que ainsi on n'a jamais
accepté de construire de logements
sociaux
et parce que hors ainsi les loyers sont
trop élevés donc en fait à montfermeil
et clichy-sous-bois ya beaucoup de gens
pauvres dont des immigrés et au raincy
ben y'a pas beaucoup de gens aux revenus
modestes dont il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'immigrés alors la conséquence c'est
quoi c'est qu'un offert mais y est à
clichy sous bois bas dans les écoles il
ya beaucoup d'enfants d'immigrés et
d'enfants de milieux défavorisés pour
lesquels il faut un soutien particulier
alors que au raincy et bien il n'y a pas
ce brassage alors je crois que là on a
effectivement un problème si on veut pas
qu'ee de ghettos d'une part il faut
s'occuper des logements sociaux
comme je l' ai dit tout à l'heure pour
que les gens ne les fuit pas pour que
les relations humaines soit possible
pour que ce ne soit pas des quartiers
laissés à l'abandon que ce soit des
endroits où il ya une vie sociale et
deuxièmement il faut que dans les autres
villes celles où aujourd'hui on ne peut
pas aller
il y est aussi la possibilité pour les
immigrés de s'installer de nouveau posé
une question vous expliquer les immigrés
aux français ce que vous êtes en train
de faire
lorsque vous parlez aux immigrés est ce
que vous leur expliquez les français je
me souviens dans votre livre vous êtes
vous à la fin de votre livre la page 139
140 vous raconter une histoire et la fin
mon peuple
enfin oui alors vous raconter une
histoire vous êtes dans le métro c'est
la fin j'avais sauvegarde 147 abord je
me suis allé
vous êtes dans le métro et il ya en face
de vous un homme qui vous regardent d'un
air méchant il regarde surtout votre
petite main bien très bien on discute
vaut discuter
il vous dit ça me plait pas vous lui
demandez pourquoi si vous dis parce que
je suis raciste
alors ça vous étonne voulu mais pourquoi
êtes-vous raciste il vous dit c'est
parce que ma soeur a été violée par
trois noirs aient voulu expliquer que
les noirs sont positives violeur bien
entendu alors lorsque vous avez raison
d' expliquer ça à cet homme mais est ce
que vous expliquez aux émigrés les
problèmes de cohabitation des français
les problèmes qui peuvent se poser aux
français les irritations le bruit pour
certains c'est ce que j'essaye de vous
égarer eric d'abattage des rites
d'abattage
on a beaucoup exagéré cette histoire ce
sont seulement des rumeurs mais vous
avez qu'on parle d'assimilation
lorsqu'on parle d'intégration pour moi
c'est facile
est ce que est ce que je peux répondre
fini de petites secondes ben moi c'est
très facile j'habite à côté de chez
monsieur fabius je vais acheter depuis
que ma femme est morte je fais mon
marché je vais acheter les fruits c'est
un algérien il ya une espagnole le
fromage c'est un italien et dimanche est
le journal chez un kurde
bon alors c'est très facile mais pour
moi le problème ne se pose pas c'est un
marseille qui se pose c'est dans
certains quartiers du 1er arrondissement
de lyon
c'est à givors qui se pose est ce que
vous expliquez ça en lui leur disant
pour être assimilée qu'il faut se mettre
à la portée des offres et comprendre il
faut que chacun comprenne aujourd'hui et
bien effectivement et je voudrais le
dire ce soir d'ailleurs aux immigrés qui
nous écoutent y en a un certain nombre
qui pensent que ils sont trop rejeter et
que on n'arrivera jamais à faire reculer
le racisme
je voudrais leur dire d'abord qu'il faut
être optimiste et il faut y croire que
le combat qu'on mène
il a rassemblé de plus en plus de gens
ces dernières années et que il y a en
france des gens qui ont un état d'esprit
suffisamment ouvert pour pouvoir
accueillir les immigrés dans la société
française que ça a été possible pour les
italiens souvenez-vous des [ __ ] ça a
été possible pour les pollack
ça a été possible pour les gueule de
[ __ ] dont aujourd'hui on dit qu'ils
sont bien intégrés la deuxième chose que
je le redis une caserne nous battre sur
scène dollars
en pleine nuit amouroux la deuxième
chose c'est nous nous battons tous
ensemble immigrés ou français différents
comme moi qui suis un français de
couleur pour ne pas subir le racisme
mais il faut aussi que nous acceptions
effectivement les règles de la société
française ses valeurs ses valeurs qui
sont celles des droits de l'homme qui
sont des valeurs qui donnent sa place à
tout un chacun qui sont les valeurs de
la république liberté égalité fraternité
et il faut peut-être faire l'effort
d'aller vers les autres
il faut peut-être faire l'effort de
comprendre pourquoi les autres nous
rejette
quels problèmes ils vivent et vous
constaterez vous le disiez vous mêmes
que ceux là même qui souvent disent les
immigrés sont trop délinquance je ne
peux pas les supporter eh bien ils ont
un collègue d'immigrés avec nîmes en
boire un coup ou alors ils discutent
avec le petit arabe qui est ouvert le
soir à 9 heures c'est à dire que quand
il y a des relations personnelles qui se
tissent et bien on change la vision des
gens donc le souci de sos racisme c'est
d'essayer de rapprocher les gens et les
comités locaux de sos racisme
ça a été très souvent l'occasion pour la
première fois pour une mère de famille
française et une mère de famille
maghrébine de se retrouver ensemble
autour d'une fête on dit les fêtes ça
sert à rien pour lutter contre le
racisme mais nous on a fait une fête un
où on a demandé aux familles de venir
avec des plats de chaque région
alors il y avait des plats thaïlandais y
avait des plats marocains y avait des
plats du berrichon parce que c'était
dans une grande ville il ya des gens qui
étaient venus d'autres régions
et puis les mères de familles se sont
rencontrés en discuter et se sont
aperçus que quand on est une mère de
famille marocaine algérienne ou
française on a les mêmes soucis c'est
que vos enfants réussissent à l'école ce
qu'ils deviennent pas des délinquants
qui sombrent pas dans la drogue qu'ils
aient pas de problème avec la police et
que demain il est un travail qui leur
plaît et bien quand les gens se
rencontrent et qui s'aperçoivent qu'ils
ont tout ça en commun ils se disent
qu'au delà de leurs différences ils ont
surtout une communauté de destin c'est
de vivre dans le même pays qui est la
france est un pays qui a des valeurs qui
font que tout le monde a ses chances ici
un doux soucieux de la montée de
l'intégrisme islamique
bien entendu je crois que ça c'est un
phénomène dont vous entendez pas ce que
vous entendez par exemple
jean les dirigeants iraniens dit là il
faut que les musulmans partout ils sont
partout où ils se trouvent
attaque la france est ce que ça vous
troubler ce que ça vous inquiète bien
entendu c'est très inquiétant
cette montée de l'intégrisme maintenant
il faut quand même rétablir aussi une
vérité les immigrés maghrébins qui
vivent en france et qui sont musulmans
d'abord ce ne sont pas des chiites ce
sont des sunnites bien et si on disait
que ce sont tous des chiites et d
intégrer c'est comme si on disait que
tous les catholiques français étaient
des intégristes de monseigneur lefebvre
donc ça c'est déjà une première chose la
deuxième jour de mon second level ne
pose pas de bon sens ce sont aussi
parfois des fanatiques et un certain
nombre d'entre eux sont aussi capables
de violence la deuxième chose c'est que
les immigrés qui vivent en france et
notamment les jeunes les enfants de
l'immigration
je pense par exemple aux jeunes filles
beurre mais vous savez ils sont pas très
pressé de tomber sous la coupe du mode
de vie traditionnel
la jeune fille beurre à la pas forcément
envie qu'on lui met un tchador et qu'on
l'envoie à la mosquée ou qu on la marie
de force de même que les jeunes filles
françaises qui venaient des provinces
autrefois un et ben il n'était pas très
pressé que ça soit l'heure les familles
qui s'occupent des à l envi d'aller à
l'école avec ses amis elle a envie
d'aller au concert elle a envie de
réussir à avoir un travail bien et donc
vous savez il n'ya pas plus de jeunes
issus de l'immigration qui sont
attachées spécialement à telle ou telle
forme de religion que deux jeunes
français la dernière chose que je
voudrais dire c'est qu'on a constaté que
là où le racisme était fort et là où
l'exclusion était très frappante et bien
effectivement il y avait un repli d'un
certain nombre d'immigrés sur leur
religion et parfois sur des formes
manipulé par l'intégrisme et donc c'est
le racisme nombre de mosquées est grand
mais le rassemblement oui et c'est très
souvent le racisme qui crée l intégrisme
et il faut comprendre que les immigrés
qui se sentent rejetés de la société
française et bien cela peuvent
effectivement avoir la tentation de
s'identifier à d'autres cultures à
d'autres phénomènes alors que les
immigrés qui ont la possibilité ici de
bénéficier de l'égalité des chances et
de s'intégrer et bien croyez moi qui
préfère souvent la devise de la
république à n'importe quel intégristes
mais une dernière chose aussi
il faut pas reprocher à des gens d'être
musulman de même qu'on reproche pas aux
gens d'être juif ou d'être protester
d'être catholique la france est un pays
laïc donc c'est un pays où chacun a le
droit de pratiquer la religion de son
choix du moment qu'ils respectent les
lois de la république et que cela
n'empiète pas sur le fonctionnement de
la société
merci henri amouroux 3,3 sondage rapide
fait pas que vous parliez vote des
immigrés aux élections municipales
vous avez dit que vous étiez pour les
français sont partagés favorables 44 %
opposé 43% surprise si je constate moi
que ça progresse parce que là il ya un
équilibre 1 44 % sont favorables 43%
sont opposés alors qu'il ya encore
quelques mois dans les sondages
eh bien on sait que c'était à peine un
tiers des français qui était favorable
au droit de vote des immigrés je crois
que c'est pas encore suffisant mais que
c'est une idée qui fait son chemin
deuxième question sur un thème soulevé
par henri amouroux estimez-vous que dans
les médias en parlent trop souvent des
incidents racistes pas assez souvent
ou juste comme il faut trop souvent 38%
passé souvent 16%
juste comme il faut 34% donc juste comme
il faut et pas assez souvent ce sont les
gens qui pensent qu'on en parle
finalement quand il y en a ça fait plus
de 50%
ceux qui pensent qu'on en parle trop
souvent eh bien je crois qu'il faut les
convaincre que c'est un vrai problème en
france qu'il y ait des gens qui meurent
uniquement parce qu'ils sont des
immigrés que c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas digne de la france
et à quoi personne n'a rien à gagner
parce qu'il faut comprendre qu'après
c'est l'engrenage de la violence
1 si les immigrés ont toujours le
sentiment d'être des victimes
eh bien on va on va voir aussi se
développer des phénomènes de
radicalisation non je crois qu'il faut
dire les choses c'est le rôle des médias
quand elles se passent sans les exagérer
et le rôle des associations de lutte
contre le racisme comme la nôtre c'est
d'essayer de prévenir ces incidents en
essayant de comprendre pourquoi ils se
sont passées comment on peut changer les
mentalités en changeant la réalité
quotidienne dans laquelle vivent les
gens troisième question qui a été posée
société multiraciale
est ce que c'est un atout ou est ce que
c'est un handicap questions posées de
façon un peu ambigu oui on sait que moi
j'ai jamais parlé des martys raciale ou
est intégrée ou si elle la supprimer les
différences très fortement un atout 34%
un handicap j'en retiens simplement
s'ils voulaient que ça n'est pas rejetée
d'être une société multiraciale est pas
un concept rejeté par les français mais
ça c'est important 34 % des gens qui
comprennent que c'est un atout je suis
sûr que beaucoup plus de gens le
comprendre s ils savaient que
l'immigration en france c'est marie
curie qui s'appelait sklodowska elle
était polonaise et ça a été un prix
nobel de la paix français c'est
évidemment ils vont tant qu'ils étaient
italiens c'est isabelle adjani qui est
arabe c'est albert schweitzer qui a été
prix nobel de la paix et qui était lui
d'origine allemande c'est ça
l'immigration en france ce sont tous
ceux qui ont permis à la france du fer
et du charbon comme on dit dans les
années 30 d'être la france de
l'expansion c'est à dire la france des
mines
ce sont tous ceux qui ont permis à la
france d'être le pays de l'automobile
pendant les années 50 et les années 60
ce sont les immigrés maghrébins c'est ça
la toux de l'immigration et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui rejeter les immigrés qui
sont ici c'est se priver d'atouts
supplémentaires pour demain demain c'est
à dire 1992 la france rentre dans
l'europe
notre principal concurrent et qui sera
aussi notre principal partenaire c'est
l'allemagne l'allemagne
d'après les chiffres récents est devenue
le premier exportateur mondial devant
les états unis et le japon
est ce que vous croyez que la france
peut se passer de tous ceux qui sont ici
de toutes les intelligences qui sont ici
de tous les futurs petit marie curie
albert schweitzer yves montand qui sont
les enfants des immigrés d'aujourd'hui
et je crois que effectivement c'est un
c'est important mais ce n'est pas encore
suffisant que les gens comprennent que
l'immigration c'est un atout pour la
france de demain elle s'est fait une
autre question
oui sur le projet de réforme du code de
nationalité cette question précise
dans le cas où les enfants d immigrés de
la deuxième génération ne voudrait pas
satisfaire aux obligations du service
national en france
à ce moment-là êtes vous d'accord pour
qu'il retourne dans le pays d'origine de
leurs parents alors il existe
aujourd'hui une convention entre la
france et l'algérie sur le service
militaire pour le pro quoi exactement
c'est un problème qui existe pour une
douzaine de pays ça existe avec le
paraguay ça existe avec des tas de pays
européens et d'amérique latine problèmes
franco elle jouit il ya plus d'immigrés
algériens et donc les jeunes franco
algérien c'est à dire les jeunes de
parents algériens qui sont nés en france
et qui ont grandi en france peuvent
choisir entre faire leur service
militaire en france ou faire leur
service militaire en algérie parce que
ce qui se passait avant qu'ils aient une
convention c'est qu'ils étaient obligés
de le faire dans les deux pays va lui
faire d'abord une fois en france et
ensuite une fois en âge
eh bien écoutez il y a des chiffres du
ministère de la défense qui viennent
d'être publiés et qui montre que sur 72
mille jeunes algériens il y en a 91 %
qui ont choisi de faire leur service
militaire en france sur que l'exercice
sur six années sur kci classe d'âge
surtout les jeunes qui sont nés entre
1963 et 1968 je fais cette raison été un
peu faussé parce qu'il ya eu des reports
d'une année sur l'autre dans certaines
périodes tout à fait et on avait des
chiffres voilà il paraissait écrasant et
on n'a raté que 50% des jeunes franco
algériens allaient faire leur service
militaire en algérie
quatre vingt onze pour cent d'accord
c'est une note signée de monsieur andré
giraud ministre de la question n'était
pas celle là
la question de la question donc l'arrêt
ailleurs la réponse est claire qu'est-ce
que vous avez que c'est que ces jeunes
ils sont à la fois français parce que la
france c'est leur pays c'est le pays où
ils sont nés et c'est le pays où ils
vivent bien et puis ils sont aussi
algériens parce que leurs parents sont
algériens
il se trouve que la double nationalité
reconnu par les deux états et donc il a
fallu passer une convention pour que ces
jeunes n'est pas à faire leur service
militaire deux fois sinon ça voulait
dire qu'il faisait trois ans de service
militaire
ce qui est important c'est que l'immense
majorité de ces jeunes qui vivent en
france choisissent de faire leur service
militaire en france dont qui choisissent
bel et bien la voie de l'intégration
corps et les autres bas les autres c'est
une minorité de 9%
la loi a aménagé pour eux ce système qui
fait que ils vont faire leur service
militaire en algérie deux ans moi j'en
connais un certain nombre il en tire pas
forcément tous un bilan très positif en
algérie après votre service militaire
non c'est une convention entre eux de
toute façon alors il faut bien savoir
que la réforme du code de la nationalité
ne changerait rien à cette réalité c'est
une convention entre la france et
l'algérie qui évite que des jeunes est à
faire deux fois leur service militaire
moi je crois que c'est un aménagement
technique qui est plutôt réaliste bien
albert du roy un quart d'heure avec
albert du roy
bonsoir on a commencé à parler du code
de nationalité on parle beaucoup de la
nationalité depuis le début de
l'émission et je voudrais simplement
vous nous donner votre définition de ce
que c'est qu'une nationalité que la
nationalité française par exemple qu'est
ce que ces quatre français va être
français c'est participer à cette
communauté de destin que sont les gens
qui vivent en france et qui adhèrent
tous un certain nombre de valeurs qui
sont les valeurs de la république
avec sa devise qui sont la philosophie
des droits de l'homme et qui pensent
qu'ils doivent se définir des règles
communes à respecter pour cet avenir en
commun
alors en fait c'est un hasard très
souvent de circonstances et de volonté
pourquoi de circonstance je prends mon
exemple personnel bas parce que j'ai des
parents français
j'ai pas choisi la nationalité de mes
parents je suis né français
et puis de volonté parce qu'ensuite
après tout j'aurais pu renoncer à être
français à choisir d'aller vivre dans un
autre pays mais la france c'est mon pays
c'est le pays que j'aime c'est le pays
où j'ai mes amis donc j'ai décidé que je
voulais faire ma vie ici que j'allais
continuer il ya donc d'une part une
décision un certain moment au moment où
on est adulte décision d'être ou de
devenir ou de rester français ya une
volonté il ya une volonté et c'est par
exemple le cas pour les jeunes issus de
l'immigration puisque là je crois qu'on
va parler de la réforme du code de la
nationalité
bien les jeunes issus de l'immigration
ils sont nés en france de parents
étrangers bien et à leur majorité
dans le système actuel ils peuvent
devenir français c'est un droit où ils
peuvent y renoncer on a dit qu'il
devenait automatiquement français c'est
pas vrai tous les ans il y en a environ
1200 1300 qui renonce à la nationalité
française d'envoyer un choix mais a donc
c'est là aussi une part de circonstances
et de volonté et chacun d'entre nous
pour réfléchir et s'apercevoir qu'il ya
une part de circonstance eux aussi c'est
une part de circonstances mais l'onf a
choisi lui que leurs parents les facs
network dans tous les cas de gens qui
sont étrangers et en france
par hasard par les hasards de la vie le
fait de leur demander à un certain
moment de décider par un acte
administratif quelconque de d'être
français ça vous semble normal alors là
vous parlez des immigrés qui arrivent en
france
oui ou qui sont nés là il sait pas des
immigrés sylvie sonné c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire dans un moment à 19h
choisi et ça c'est très important ce ne
sont pas des immigrés ils ont jamais
pris un bateau ou un avion pour venir en
france
ils sont nés ici ils ont jamais vécu
ailleurs pourquoi voulez vous les
appelez des immigrés vous pouvez dire
que au regard de la loi
un certain nombre d'entre eux sont des
étrangers de nationalités je repose ma
question d'une autre viol vous savez il
ya eu qu'à eu un débat sur le fait de
savoir si quelqu'un qui n'était pas
français devaient un certain moment
manifesté la volonté est demandé de
devenir français c'est normal je suis à
partir du moment où c'est l'adhésion que
vous définissiez tout à l'heure c'est
normal alors moi je suis pour deux
principes
pour ce qui est du code de la
nationalité et des enfants issus de
l'immigration
le premier principe c'est l'égalité des
droits et des chances et le deuxième
principe c'est la volonté alors ça
signifie la chose suivante si on veut
faire une réforme du code de la
nationalité pour faire plaisir à
l'extrême droite
comme j'ai le sentiment que c'est le cas
actuellement alors que pourtant monsieur
chalandon avait réussi à enterrer la
réforme mais jean marie le pen est passé
à l'heure de vérité et c'était un
mercredi le jeudi le premier ministre
sortait le projet de réforme du code de
la nationalité et ensuite on a créé une
commission
si c'est pour faire plaisir à l'extrême
droite ça va se faire dans un contexte
qui va forcément déboucher sur des
mesures d'exclusion comme dans le
premier projet par contre si on veut
faire une réforme du code de la
nationalité qui favorise l'intégration
et je crois que ça c'est le souci de la
majorité des français il faut faire en
sorte que ces enfants d'immigrés
deviennent des petits français comme les
autres qu'ils puissent ne pas être
marginalisés et qu'ils prennent toute
leur part dans la société française
alors si c'est ça le souci
nous nous sommes prêts à faire des
propositions et nous faisons la
proposition suivante c'est qu'on
s'inspire de ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis qui est un principe libéral
c'est à dire que dès la naissance
tous les enfants d'étrangers qui
naissent sur le sol américain ont la
nationalité américaine
donc je propose qu'en france des enfants
d'étrange
et qui naissent sur le sol français
puissent être considérés comme des
petits français dès leur naissance et
que comme ça quand ils sont à l'école et
qui sont sur le banc de l'école à côté
de leurs petits camarades qui sont
français et bien on puisse pas leur dire
alors qu'ils suivent la même scolarité
qui sont nés dans la même maternité
qu'ils habitent dans les mêmes quartiers
qu'on puisse pas leur dire toi pour
l'instant on te laisse aller à l'école
mais quand tu auras 18 ans peut-être
qu'on décidera qu'en fait tu es pas
vraiment français qu'on dira qu est ce
que tu fais à mes 20 ans empêchera de
continuer mais à conditions et alors
mais à condition qu'ils respectent les
principes de cette communauté de destin
était rare que vous définissiez tout à
l'heure comme les autres enfants comme
les enfants de français mais il faut
leur donner l'égalité des chances et il
faut avoir confiance dans les valeurs de
la société française et dans sa capacité
d'intégration
si ces enfants dès qu'ils ont cinq six
ans ils s'aperçoivent qu'ils sont
traités comme des étrangers alors que
c'est le seul pays où ils ont jamais
vécu
comment voulez vous qu'on leur donne
toutes les chances de s'intégrer par
contre si quand ils ont cinq six ans on
leur fait bien sentir que d'eux mêmes
qu'ils ont droit d'aller à la même école
que les autres on considère qu' ils ont
le droit de vivre dans ce pays comme les
autres
eh bien je pense qu'effectivement ils
s'intégreront naturellement parce que
c'est leur pays à la france
et alors ce que je propose c'est que
alors majorité à 18 ans s'ils veulent
renoncer à la nationalité française et
ne garder que la nationalité de leurs
parents car après tout on sait que c'est
le cas d'une minorité je vous ai montré
qu'en ce moment c'est environ 1200 et
1300 jeunes par an sur 20 milles et bien
qu'à ce moment là ils aient la
possibilité de décliner leur nationalité
française au moment où ils ont 18 ans ce
principe vous savez nous ne l'avons pas
inventé comme je vous ai dit d'abord
nous avons été regardée aux états unis
et deuxièmement c'est ce qui se passe en
ce moment pour les enfants des couples
mixtes c'est à dire 20 mille enfants
parents qui ont un parent français et un
parent étranger est bien de 0,1 à 18 ans
ils ont les deux nationalités
et puis à 18 ans soit ils gardent les
deux soient ils sont obligés de choisir
entre l'une des deux s'il n'y a pas
d'accord entre les deux pays de leurs
parents dont vous voyez il suffirait
simplement de s'inspirer de ce principe
qui fonctionne pour les autres enfants
et de faciliter ainsi leur adhésion à la
société française aurait eu beaucoup de
questions vous posez moi d'avoir aimé un
peu long mais je crois que bien plus
long on a vu tout à l'heure
un des centres d'intérêt principaux des
françaises gré de la nationale je
voudrais qu'elles sont plus brèves
savoir ce que vous répondez ce que vous
répondriez à des observations que l'on
entend souvent parce que les médias
parlent beaucoup des problèmes de
racisme comme rien ne roule dénoncer
tout à l'heure mais on en parle beaucoup
aussi partout dans la rue dans les cafés
et terra donc avec le reflet de la
réalité
le on entend souvent une réflexion comme
celle ci par exemple à compétences
égales
il est normal quand un emploi est libre
de privilégier un français par rapport à
un immigré et ça c'est scandaleux
vous vous rendez compte c'est ce que
j'ai montré avec cette histoire d'une
entreprise qui ne veut pas des
maghrébins et des antillais parce que ça
ça veut dire qu'on tousse gentille et ne
sont pas des étrangers à ma connaissance
mais oui mais quand on commence en
disant c'est la préférence nationale
eh bien on sait où ça se termine ça se
termine avec des gens qui lisent
je ne prends pas les immigrés et je ne
prends pas non plus les antillais je ne
prends pas les immigrés les antillais et
puis demain quelqu'un dira je ne prends
pas non plus les juifs 1
alors où est ce que ça s'arrête ça c'est
un système extrêmement dangereux de
diviser la population qui vit en france
en différentes catégories et de dire il
ya ceux qui ont le droit d'avoir un
travail d'avoir un logement décent ou
d'aller à l'école et puis il ya ceux qui
n'ont pas le droit
lorsque le leader du front national est
passé à l'heure de vérité la dernière
fois il a proposé qu'ils aient des
hôpitaux pour français des hôpitaux pour
immigrés alors pourquoi pas des écoles
pour français des écoles pour immigrer
ça un nom pour malades du sida ou si oui
mais ça a un nom ce système 1
ça s'appelle le développement séparé des
quartiers pour ceux ci et des quartiers
pour cela que l'apartheid autre bain
nous c'est l'intégration c'est le
contraire de l'apartheid autre réflexion
que l'on entend dans le prolongement de
la première que je fais que j'ai fait
c'est il était normal que la france
accueille de nombreux immigrés au moment
de l'expansion maintenant c'est la crise
il est normal qu'on freine ou qu'on
arrête l'immigration mais elle est
arrêtée elle est arrêtée depuis 1974
oui l'immigration légale est arrêté non
attention sauf le regroupement familial
oui depuis 12 ans elle est arrêtée et
donc ça c'est une position qui a été
finalement prise par le gouvernement de
l'époque qui a été maintenue par
les gouvernements suivants maintenant
moi je voudrais faire une remarque
nous sommes dans une période
effectivement où ce serait illusoire de
faire croire à des gens qui sont dans
des pays du tiers monde que en venant en
europe ou en venant en france ils
peuvent trouver des ressources qu'ils
n'ont pas chez eux et le vrai problème
si on veut arrêter le flux d'immigration
clandestine nous on a parlé tout à
l'heure c'est non seulement de s'occuper
du secteur économique en france qui en
profitent mais c'est aussi de s'occuper
du développement dans les pays du sud
car tant qu'il ya les deux tiers de la
planète qui vit dans des conditions on
ne peut pas assurer sa subsistance ya
effectivement des hommes et des femmes
qui sont amenés à s'arracher de leurs
terres pour réussir à faire vivre leur
famille et sam surtout si c est nous
vieux ça c'est aussi une responsabilité
que nous avons et je crois qu'il faut
savoir c'est une des grandes
préoccupations des jeunes ça va être un
des enjeux finalement pour notre
génération d'ici la fin du siècle de
savoir comment par exemple l'europe qui
va se construire en 1992
ça peut être autre chose que disons une
espèce de continents égoïste mais ça
doit être au contraire un continent qui
essayent de nouer de nouvelles relations
avec le sud
il ya une proposition claire et oui
excusez moi que j'ai il ya des idées là
aussi là pour aider à les payer vous ne
donnerez pas tout de ce soir
certainement mais parce que je voudrais
interrogé aussi n'est pas que le
président et le porte parole d'esso aux
racismes vous êtes au 6e rang qui est en
tout cas moitié antillais vous êtes
aussi un jeune et y est d'aider des
choses que je voudrais savoir de la part
de ces antillais ou de ce jeune les
antilles d'abord brièvement il ya des
problèmes là-bas il ya des
indépendantistes vous êtes
indépendantiste non moi je pense que
c'est aux antillais qui vivent aux
antilles de décider s'ils veulent ou non
l'indépendance
pour l'instant ce n'est pas une position
majoritaire ça c'est la première
remarque
la deuxième remarque c'est qu'un certain
nombre de gens qui disent être
indépendantiste sont surtout aujourd'hui
des terroristes bien que je crois pas
qu'on puisse faire progresser une idée
en utilisant la violence et la troisième
remarque c'est que par contre parce que
c'est quand même un peu aussi
des îles dont je me sens proche et que
j'ai eu l'occasion d'y aller il ya trop
de choses qui se dessine encore en
métropole je veux dire c'est pas
possible que la martinique la guadeloupe
qui sont donc les endroits que je
connais dont je peux parler qui sont à
plus de 7000 kilomètres de la france
soit gérée depuis des bureaux qui sont à
paris et cela effectivement c'est un
problème il ya sûrement plus d'autonomie
plus de décisions locales qui doivent
pouvoir être prises sur place que le
fait est ce que le fait que les antilles
soit française vous semble une anomalie
de l'histoire
en tout cas c'est effectivement quelque
chose d'un petit peu étrange mais vous
savez il ya beaucoup de choses dans
l'histoire qui sont étranges il ya des
millions de chinois qui vivent à san
francisco à new york
ça peut sembler une anomalie de
l'histoire mais le monde est comme ça
donc il se trouve que l'histoire a fait
que la martinique et la guadeloupe
et bien aujourd'hui ça fait partie de la
france bien est-ce que ça durera
toujours
j'en sais rien mais de toute façon c'est
aux gens qui vivent en martinique et en
guadeloupe de décider on va revenir tout
de suite au terrorisme une autre
question parce que bon cette émission
pour une fois exceptionnellement n'est
pas diffusée en nouvelle calédonie pour
des raisons bizarre alors il faudrait
aussi faut quand même qu'on parle de
nouvelle calédonie pourrait néanmoins
donner une vraie raison à l'interdiction
ça veut dire que en gros est ce que vous
pourriez dire de subversif sur la
nouvelle calédonie non il n'y a rien à
dire de subversif sur la nouvelle
calédonie en plus je ne suis pas allé en
nouvelle calédonie donc zeev et har avis
sur le référendum c'est pas un problème
dont je peux parler en connaisseur ou un
spécialiste
maintenant mon sentiment personnel c'est
qu'il faut à tout prix éviter dans cette
île que on en arrive à cette situation
de tensions et de violences entre les
communautés qui a débouché sur ce que
l'on sait en algérie 1 où finalement
quand le pays est devenu indépendant et
bien ça s'est fait en chassant une des
communautés
donc à mon avis le premier souci des
gens qui ont des responsabilités pour
s'occuper de ce dossier qu'il soit ici à
paris un outil soit là bas dans ce
territoire en nouvelle calédonie c'est
d'éviter cette situation d'affrontement
et d'exploiter les tensions qui existent
aujourd'hui entre les communautés mais
la deuxième chose c'est que mon pari
personnel mais je suis pas un
spécialiste c'est que cette île elle va
devenir indépendante
un jour ou l'autre vous savez il ya un
grand penseur de droite qui s'appelait
raymond aron
qui a dit bien avant tout le monde que
l'algérie serait indépendante savait pas
plus quand il a dit ça moi j'ai lu
raymond aron il me semble que pour les
mêmes raisons que celles qu il expliqué
à propos de l'algérie
la nouvelle calédonie un jour sera
indépendante
quel lien elle va garder avec la france
je n'en sais rien c'est celui qu'elles
gardent des liens à propos de la
nouvelle calédonie ce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure à propos des antilles
c'est à ceux qui habitent à tous ceux
qui habitent de décider bien entendu
donc là policiers gaudin n'a pas avoir
un léger un kanak qui voudraient
interdire un certain nombre de blancs de
nouvelle calédonie le droit de vote dans
un référendum d'autodétermination vous
semble une position anormale
excusez moi albert ii roi je vois très
bien où vous voulez en venir vous voulez
que je rentre dans un débat très
politique
non alors que je crois qu'on est quand
même assez loin de notre sujet moi je
pense que c'est aux gens qui vivent dans
cette île tous ensemble de décider de
leur avenir bien alors est-ce que ça
sert à quelque chose aujourd'hui
d'organiser le référendum qui va être
organisé est-ce que ça va vraiment faire
avancer le schmilblick comme on dit
parce que c'est ça qui doit être le
premier souci c'est de faire avancer la
situation
moi je ne le sais pas et je pense que il
faut en tout cas à s'apercevoir que un
certain nombre de choses peuvent
favoriser l'affrontement alors qu'un
certain nombre d'autres choses
pourraient peut-être favoriser le
dialogue
on change de sujet puisque vous avez
tout dit là dessus le terrorisme et il
vous l'avait condamné très nettement en
ce qui concerne des antilles tout à
l'heure est ce qu'il vous semble parfois
justifiées le terrorisme n'est jamais
justifié le la philosophie au nom de
laquelle je me bats contre le racisme
c'est la philosophie des droits de
l'homme
c'est cette idée là c'est cette
conception humaniste de la société qui
rassemble aujourd'hui des milliers de
gens en france dans le combat de sos
racisme
c'est au nom de cette même philosophie
que je ne peux pas supporter le
terrorisme ce soir j'ai invité sur ce
plateau joëlle kauffmann je les invitais
d'abord par amitié et par solidarité
parce que à ses côtés nous avons essayé
comme des tas d'autres de faire ce qui
était possible pour qu'on n'oublie pas
jean paul kauffmann pour qu'on n'oublie
pas les otages du liban et parce que je
veux dire qu'il n'y a aucune cause qui
jamais ne peut justifier l'utilisation
du terrorisme et que ceux qui font ça
sont des criminels
d'abord parce qu'il tue des gens
aveuglément et parce qu'en plus tard
retombe toujours sur d'autres est-ce
qu'il faut dénoncer quand on les connaît
à mon avis moi personnellement je ne
connais pas de terroristes mais j'en
connaîtrai je ferai tout ce qui est en
mon pouvoir pour qu'il soit
effectivement arrêté c'est à dire que
ces affiches qui sont appelés appel à
témoin et que d'autres appellent appel à
la délation
ça ne vous choque pas en ce qui concerne
le terrorisme écoutez moi je n'ai pas à
juger des méthodes qui sont utilisées
par les services crs de trélazé avoir
mis d'accord mais là vous voulez
m'entraîner et je vois dans un débat
ensuite sur monsieur pasqua vous voulez
que je prenne des positions positives
alors que ça n'allait pas alors merci
alors que ça n'est pas ça n'est pas le
sujet moi je n'ai pas de de choses à
dire sur l'action des services qui sont
concernés pour lutter contre le
terrorisme
je pense comme tous les citoyens
français qui font tout ce qui est
possible mais je crois aussi et ça c'est
évident que la lutte contre le
terrorisme évidemment ne doit pas
empiéter sur les droits de l'homme sinon
les terroristes auraient gagné 6 pour
lutter contre le terrorisme ont
transformé le pays en état de guerre et
qu'on supprime à toutes les libertés
et bien finalement les terroristes
auraient réussi à supprimer les droits
de l'homme en france je change tout à
fait le sujet parce que je ne voulais
pas du tout vous entraîner à parler
monsieur pasqua le est ce que la france
fait assez je ne parle pas des sept
députés qui sont allés récemment contre
l'afrique du sud de l'apartheid en
afrique du sud
écoutez à propos de ces sept députés moi
même je vais vous dire quelque chose
l'an passé ça c'est des phrases et j'ai
voulu justement l'évacuer parce que
j'imagine ce que vous en pensez vous
être contre quoi non mais non seulement
je suis content mais c'est absolument
incroyable ce qui s'est passé mais c'est
bien que les gens qui me claire et pas
celle là je vais répondre à votre
question albert du roy
je pense que la france pourrait faire
plus pour aider les noirs d'afrique du
sud et tous ceux qui en afrique du sud
se bat contre l'apartheid et je pense
que ce qui est grave c'est que des
députés de l'assemblée nationale
française qui vont en voyage à
l'étranger qui représentent le pays des
droits de l'homme puissent faire des
déclarations comme celles que je vais
vous lire ils ont fait dans valeurs
actuelles
c'est un député qui dit il n'ya pas
d'affrontement entre noirs et blancs
les affrontements opposent toujours des
noirs et un autre qui dit en fait
je ne crois pas que le droit de vote
intéresse les noirs la démocratie telle
que nous la concevons en occident
l'aurait étrangères en grand les noirs
ne connaissent pas leur bonheur en
afrique du sud france doit faire leur
choix en plus la france doit faire quoi
en plus elle doit pratiquer l'embargo
d'une façon systématique et le douar de
nouveaux rompre les relations
diplomatiques qui ont été renoués alors
vous savez dès son toutou est venue en
france il ya deux ans bien et il a livré
en france ce message qu'il livre partout
où il va il a dit la chose suivante il
faut sanctionner l'apartheid les pays
démocratiques ne peuvent pas continuer à
avoir des relations avec l'afrique du
sud comme si de rien n'était on peut
essayer de manger avec le diable même
avec une longue cuillère on finit
toujours par se faire brûler vif donc ce
que nous demandent les gens qui lutte
contre l'apartheid en afrique du sud
c'est d'isoler le régime sud africain de
l'isoler diplomatiquement et de l'isoler
économiquement
vous savez que l'afrique du sud vient
compte parmi ses principaux partenaires
économiques
non seulement les états unis la grande
bretagne mais également la france qui
est je crois au sixième rang de ses
exportations qui lui fournit notamment
du matériel militaire et alors vous
pensez pas est ce que vous ne pensez pas
que toutes les victimes de toutes les
dictatures attendent des démocraties la
même chose et que ça conduirait aux
liens des droits de l'homme à avoir des
relations économiques ou commerciales
avec un très petit nombre de pays bas je
vous prends l'exemple d'une autre
dictature la pologne et bien en pologne
les gens qui se battent contre la
dictature et au premier chef lech walesa
ont demandé aux pays démocratique de ne
pas imposer de sanctions économiques à
la pologne
c'est une question qui dépend de la
façon dont ça se passe dans le pays en
afrique du sud depuis 25 ans les noirs
nous voulons que vous sanctionner notre
pays parce que notre pays il continue à
pouvoir faire vivre l'apartheid grâce à
ses relations extérieures grâce aux
profits qu'il tire de ses relations avec
les pays occidentaux
je voulais revenir quelques instants à
la la politique française puisque que
vous le vouliez ou non et sous une forme
ou sous une autre vous y jouer un rôle
est-ce que
s'il le continuer dans le langage du
discours qu'il tient est ce que vous
seriez partisans de d'interdire le front
national mais pourquoi voulez vous qu'on
interdise un parti politique
à quoi ça sert moi je suis pour que la
france soit une démocratie et le reste
est donc il ya des gens qui se
présentent aux élections s'il y a des
électeurs pour les envoyer dans les
différentes assemblées bien c'est que
c'est l'expression de la démocratie
moi ce que je veux c'est pas casser le
thermomètre 1 c'est faire baisser la
fièvre
alors c'est à dire qu'il faut faire
reculer cette idée incroyable que par le
racisme on va réussir à résoudre les
problèmes de la société française que en
désignant les immigrés comme boucs
émissaires on va faire baisser le
chômage
moi j'aimerais bien qu'un seul homme
politique sérieux de droite ou de gauche
m'expliquer comment en expulsant 3
millions d'immigrés
on peut créer 3 millions d'emplois et on
peut résoudre le problème du chômage
personne ne peut l'expliquer donc il
faut dire ça aux gens et il faut faire
baisser
effectivement l'influencent du front
national il s'agit pas de l'interdire
par des mesures répressives
autre question politique vous avez des
gens dont vous dites souvent du bien des
hommes politiques dirigeants politiques
dont vous dites souvent du bien dans en
tout cas trois grandes familles
politiques socialistes udf rpr
est-ce que vous n'auriez pas aimé en
voir des trois familles ce soir dans ce
studio et deuxièmement si oui est-ce que
c'était impossible d'un côté ou d'un
autre
moi je crois qu'il ya des gens bien dans
tous les partis politiques et qu'il ya
dans tous les partis politiques des gens
qui sont moins bien bien aujourd'hui sur
ce plateau moi j'ai invité mes amis j'ai
invité des gens que j'aime bien les gens
venir a souhaité d'hommes politiques
exactement et donc bombe à cette fois on
n'a pas invité d'un homme politique sera
peut-être pour une autre fois comme le
disent le soulignait alain duhamel tout
à l'heure le
cette émission a eu une presse comme on
dit considérable avant les dom adhèrent
tous les quotidiens tous les quotidiens
parisiens sauf un ce matin du manic les
rides
ça vous étonne non j'ai pas fais
attention je dois vous avouer je lis pas
l'humanité tous les matins mais ça ne
vous étonne pas d'une sur le plan sur le
plan justement de vote de votre combat
écoutez c'est à eux qu'il faut poser la
question ils rédigent leur journal comme
ils le veulent et en fonction de ce que
à temps de leurs lecteurs je ne sais pas
mais effectivement c'est peut-être
étonnant qu'un journal
mais enfin cesser leur liberté alors il
ya une vous avez beaucoup fait référence
à des sondages donc vous y croyez alors
je voudrais vous soumettre à une
question de sondage qui est qui a été
posée d'ailleurs dans le journal
non rien de rien mais rouge dans le
figaro magazine qu'est-ce qui vous
définit le mieux
alors il ya un certain nombre de
propositions le sexe la religion la race
la classe sociale la profession l'âge la
nationalité française
qu'est-ce qui vous définit le mieux moi
ou c'est ma personnalité
ce qui me définit le mieux c'est un
ensemble de toutes ces choses là je
crois pas qu'il puisse ça c'est le
problème de certains sondages on peut
pas toujours répondre par oui ou par
l'anp et que tous ceux que vous avez
cités tout à l'heure on en y faisant
référence c'était des sondages où il
fallait pas moi ce qui me définit le
mieux c'est probablement d'être un jeune
homme français
voilà donc ça serait à la fois le sexe
l'âge et la nationalité alors dans le
même sondage quand même je ne résiste
pas au plaisir de poser la question dans
le même sondage il y avait une autre
question qui était et de vous une bulle
en entendant la marseillaise
oui un peu c'est vrai parce que je veux
vous dire c'est surtout parce que je les
ai appris à l'école primaire et à chaque
fois que j'entends la marseillaise me
revois dans ce hall d'école c'était
avant la la la fête de fin d'année en
train d'essayer d'apprendre les derniers
vers de la marseillaise et vous savez
comment on dit abreuve nos sillons tout
le monde répétait pan à la fin et voilà
ça me fait toujours penser à ça c'est
une question qui avait été posée aussi à
laurent fabius ou à laquelle je crois
plutôt qu'il avait répondu spontanément
d'ailleurs alors jésus donne quand même
les réponses du sondage
en comparaison 60 % des gens sont émus
entendant la marseillaise mais seulement
37% des
bah je sais pas pourquoi moi ça m'émeut
une perte du sens de la patrie
non je crois pas je crois que les jeunes
sont très attachés à leur pays
je crois qu'ils sont attachés à la
patrie au sens des droits de l'homme au
sens de la devise de la république de
1789 au sens aussi où on était attaché à
la patrie tous ceux qui sont battus dans
la résistance contre les nazis pour
défendre le pays de la liberté contre
des envahisseurs barbares
je crois pas du tout que les jeunes se
détache de la patrie maintenant mon psy
c'est dans un sens franchouillard où il
faut absolument pouvoir faire la guerre
à tout le monde ça c'est tout à fait
éloigner notre état d'esprit bien
svp les questions des téléspectateurs 4
question monsieur désir combien yat-il
d'asiatiques à sos racisme le qui
s'intègrent mieux en france que d'autres
alors écoutez moi je ne tiens pas une
comptabilité des adhérents de sos
racisme par origine un ya un pays où on
fait comme ça c'est pas pour dire aux
téléspectateurs parce que il y en a
évidemment il ya des adhérents de
l'assaut est raciste qui sont d'origine
asiatique il y en a d'ailleurs dans un
peu toutes les villes de france et il
participe au combat comme les autres
mais bon il n'y a pas une classification
des adhérents autre question si on est
il vrai que vous êtes en procès
actuellement avec un fonctionnaire de
police noir que vous auriez insulté lors
d'une manifestation quand l'afrique du
sud
alors écoutez cette accusation qui a été
porté par un journal d'extrême droite
m'a amené à faire un procès à ce journal
d'extrême droite et je vous ai amené ici
les extraits du procès parce que comme
je connais les campagnes les journaux
d'extrême droite font contre moi j'ai
préféré apporter le document ce journal
a été condamné à 50 mille francs 1 à ses
dépens cinquante mille francs pour
m'avoir canonnier en me faisant cette
accusation
donc je crois que d'accord ainsi l'
affaire est réglée affaire classée et à
bonne entendeur salut à quel endroit
habité boue au milieu d'immigrés ou de
français moi écouter comme vous
comme je les dis je sais pas si vous
l'avez rappelé j'habite dans un quartier
où effectivement il ya pas mal
d'immigrés puisque c'est le 13ème
arrondissement de paris donc qui est le
quartier où effectivement vu une grande
partie la communauté asiatique
enfin dernière question la question des
lunes émission vous avez dit qu'une
carrière politique ne vous tentez pas
mais accepteriez-vous après l'élection
présidentielle un poste de secrétaire
d'état pour les droits de l'homme non
moi je sais pour un homme politique ça
moi je ne suis pas un homme politique je
suis un jeune qui avec d'autres jeunes a
lancé en leur faisant on n'était pas non
plus un homme politique
oui mais il a fait le choix de devenir
un homme politique - c'est pas du tout
ma vocation
moi je me bats pour des idées je me bats
parce que je crois que ont fait
progresser ses idées parce que je crois
qu'on apporte des solutions concrètes
aux problèmes et ma vocation je les 10
et c'est devenir enseignant et chercheur
c'est ce que j'avais à faire
et bien voici voici venir l'heure du
verdict des téléspectateurs
ce soir on a beaucoup dit que vous
jouiez votre votre jeune notoriété à
quitte ou double alors quitte ou double
la réponse de jérôme jaffré directeur
des études politiques de la sofres et
bien nous avons pris le pouls des
téléspectateurs tout au long de
l'émission comme d'habitude et je
précise d'ailleurs que malgré la période
de l'année nous avons veillé à ce que
l'échantillon reste représentatif de
l'éventail politique de l'extrême droite
à l'extrême gauche bien entendu je dirai
tout de suite doubles pour répondre à la
question de françois henri de virieu
harlem désir s'est montré un avocat très
convaincant de la lutte contre le
racisme mais il faut pondérer certains
résultats par le fait que l'émission on
le sait se passe sans débat
contradictoire pour harlem désir comme
pour tous les autres invités et certains
résultats que nous avons enregistré
comme par exemple la réponse sur le vote
aux municipales doit tenir compte de cet
élément
alors est ce qu'harlem désir s'est
montré convaincant nous avons posé la
question au cours de la soirée sur trois
sujets les moyens de lutter contre le
racisme les possibilités de coexistence
entre les français et les immigrés et
les problèmes de la jeunesse majorité de
convaincant sur les trois points entre
52% et 62%
ce qui est intéressant de noter par
exemple que c'est ce que sur les
problèmes de l'immigration jean marie le
pen quand il avait été lundi
l'heure de vérité s'était montré
convaincant auprès de 35 % de
l'échantillon de la sofres pour harlem
désir s'est 52%
il faut avoir ces deux chiffres en tête
pour comparer les choses deuxième
question est est-ce qu'il faut réformer
le code de la nationalité ce que le
gouvernement chirac doit maintenir son
projet de réforme
ou est-ce qu'il doit y renoncer nous
l'avons posée juste avant le début de
l'émission et nous l'avons posée à la
fin pour mesurer là dessus l'évolution
des téléspectateurs au cours de
l'émission la harlem désir n'a pas
réussi à inverser la tendance dominante
qui est favorable à une réforme du code
de la nationalité
49 % des téléspectateurs en fin
d'émission reste favorable 32% ils sont
défavorables
sept points de plus donc mais malgré
tout une majorité restent favorables à
l'idée d'une réforme du code de la
nationalité
troisième question est-ce que harlem
désir et sos racisme sont liés au parti
socialiste où est ce qu'ils sont
réellement indépendant du parti
socialiste la harlem désir a marqué son
indépendance politique puisque c'était
une des questions importantes qu'on se
posait avant l'émission
seulement 27 % des téléspectateurs
jugent le mouvement lié au parti
socialiste 42% l'estiment indépendant
c'est peut-être cette indépendance à
l'égard des partis politiques qui
expliquent enfin la dernière question la
bonne opinion la mauvaise opinion à
l'égard d'harlem désir que nous avons
traditionnellement poser comme pour les
autres hommes politiques avant
l'émission juste au début de l'émission
harlem désir que j'ai déjà un score
élevé 53 % de bonnes opinions juste au
début de l'émission
70 % de bonnes opinions à la fin 18 % de
mauvaises refusé dans l'aspect comique
par rapport aux 21 émissions précédentes
de l'heure de vérité c'est le record
absolu donc double voie là et bien
c'était l'heure de vérité de harlem
désir
c'était une première premier invité sans
cravate d'abord si j'excepte
des troncs seigneur de courtrai
monseigneur lustiger premier plus jeunes
invités un premier non blancs de
l'émission et quel effet ça vous a fait
à 27 ans de passer 80 minutes dans ce
fauteuil mais j'ai essayé de défendre
mes idées avec le plus de conviction
possible je vois que sur certains points
on a réussi à faire avancer sur d'autres
points moi je voudrais dire aux gens
qu'ils sont pas d'accord avec moi je
crois que ce qui nous différencie c'est
que nous nous avons confiance dans
l'avenir
finalement on est plutôt optimiste on
pense que on peut réussir l'intégration
des immigrés qu'on peut réussir à
harmoniser les relations entre français
et immigrés et peut-être que eux ils
sont moins optimistes qu'ils ont une
vision un peu plus pessimiste de
l'avenir de la société française qui
pense que les choses vont aller en se
dégradant
alors les semaines qui viennent les
jours qui viennent nous allons nous
atteler en allant dans toute la france à
les convaincre qu'en fait ça peut
marcher qu'il ya des petites choses qui
peuvent être faites pour faire avancer
la situation concrètement et que après
tout tous ensemble on est plus fort que
quand on est les uns contre les autres
voilà maintenant on va aller signer
ensemble le livre d'or prochaine invitée
mercredi 2 septembre
madame michèle barzach ministre de la
santé et de la famille bonsoir
[Musique]